Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu raum zeit dem podcast über raumfahrt und andere kosmische angelegenheiten mein name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zu nummer dreiundachtzig hier in unserer Gesprächsreihe,
und hier ging es traditionell schon auch immer viel um europa und auch die deutsche raumfahrt und speziell so die europäische perspektive das ist bisher nur hier und da mal ein wenig auf,
gebrochen.
Heute wollen wir mal ein wenig über den teich schauen uns ein phänomen geben was schon seit längerem in der raumfahrt eine ganze große welle ausgelöst hat und auch weiterhin,
ordentlich hierüber schwappt das ist natürlich die rede von spacex dem raumfahrtunternehmen aus den usa,
gegründet von elon musk das ja einiges in bewegung gebracht hat und um darüber zu sprechen begrüße ich heute mein gesprächspartner nämlich hans königsbrunn schönen guten tag.
Ja danke guten tag.
Herr königs mann sie sind bei space-x und auch schon sehr lange und mehr oder weniger von anfang an.
Kann man kann man so sehen ich war ich war damals der der vierte ingenieur sozusagen der der geheuert wurde und.
Mittlerweile ist der dritte sozusagen wieder weg und deswegen betrachte ich mich als den dritten.
Hallo.
Und es ist zehn siebzehneinhalb jahre her das war im äh im mai zweitausendzwei.
Bevor wir da vielleicht dazu kommen würde mich natürlich mal interessieren wieso ihr weg in die raumfahrt eigentlich so gelaufen ist womit pfingsten bei ihnen.
Also ich bin ich bin ich bin eigentlich eine verhinderte pilot ich wollte eigentlich mal fliegen meine augen waren nicht gut genug und damals gab's ja noch kein lasić ähm,
und dann war halt das nächste beste für mich ein kein basic also die augen korrektur die leser.
Ok
Und das nächste beste war halt ein studium von der luft und raumfahrt,
da ich familie in berlin hab und auch berlin komme weil es halt an der t u berlin dann halt entsprechend,
und ich habe halt mit flugzeugen angefangen praktisch fast das volle studium fahrzeuge durchgeführt und dann bin ich über die satellitentechnik gestolpert durch zufall mit mir.
Also luft- und raumfahrttechnik.
Luft und raumfahrt wie die beiden studiengänge sind relativ getrennt ja und und ich hatte halt flugzeuge fast durch und dann hab ich jemanden kennengelernt er arbeitet mit
tu berlin zusammen und dann war das so interessant als gedacht da mach ich noch ein bisschen ein bisschen mehr und habe praktisch völlig auf die satelliten umgeschwenkt,
und als ich dann mit dem studium fertig war gab es ein satelliten aus bremen der hit bremen seid und bremsen und tust waren nicht so richtig verschiedene flogen beide sollten beide ein shuttle fliegen,
und von daher musste ich also ziemlich genau schauen was ich machen muss und bin dann halt an die uni bremen gegangen für bremen satt für nochmal sechs sieben jahre das ging dann auch,
es ging ja auch relativ gut wir haben bremse bremse geflogen oder haben geflogen haben ihn aufgebaut mit mit mit zusammen zahn und haben ist der der fall turm an der uni bremen
und ich habe da sechs jahre daran gearbeitet und am ende eine promotion gemacht das ist einfach nicht unbedingt weil ich das wollte ich wollte nicht promovieren das ergab sich einfach so es war,
wie die zeit und dann hatte ich ein angebot aus den usa am für zwei jahre zu einer kleinen firma zu kommen als,
im prinzip und auch ein bisschen um um ein buch zu schreiben und die firma bamako kursen die gehört james james und,
zwei jahre schien so ein bisschen arme höher zu sein meine frau war begeistert wollte das auch mitmachen und da sind halt drüber nach nach los angeles.
Aus den zwei jahren wurden dann dann fünf jahre verlängert und dann haben wir eine gemacht und dann wurden meine projekte immer spannender da drüben ich habe bei blasdorf mitgemacht das war eine mondlandung,
die kommerziell geplant war das ging dann am ende auch auch pleite,
und dann ist mir über den weg gelaufen und ich bin halt eben auch dann da geblieben das war,
ich würde mal sagen das war ein paar monate bevor spacex gegründet wurde ich war mit,
war tatsächlich mit grünen warte mein damaliger chef auch ne ist ja heute präsidentin spacex und war mit ihr auf einem amateur raketen wochenende,
und da sind wir halt auch island über weggelaufen haben guten tag gesagt haben ein bisschen ein bisschen geredet,
fand ich interessant fand ich spannend was er gemacht hat er hatte damals an diesem hot house für maß gearbeitet und war einfach interessiert leute kennenzulernen so ein bisschen sich in der szene halt was da was da war kennenzulernen.
Also es war zweitausendzwei da.
Das war zweitausendzwei am anfang genau und dann.
Gab es ja auch noch kein kein tesla etcetera da war elon musk einfach nur der typ der mal paypal gemacht hat und das war's.
War damals neunundzwanzig ne und ich war ich war knappe es war neununddreißig glaube ich und das war so für mich ich war so ein bisschen,
ich wollte eigentlich nach einer neuen sachen gucken ich hatte mir schon wieder zurück in europa beworben und so sachen gemacht und dann das wlan vorbei kam war wirklich,
oder zufall das timing war gut und er rief mich dann noch zwei monate später an hat irgendwie meinen namen paar mal gehört von anderen leuten vor allen dingen halt nix.
Ich mache im prinzip ich mache alles so ein bisschen ich mache so relativ breit was man als systems engineer bezeichnen könnte ich kann kann alles ein bisschen aber nicht so richtig ne.
Das ist immer das beste an das statement das mache ich ja auch.
Na gut ich bin ich bin meine spezialisierung ist relativ es ist lager regelung von satelliten ja und auf dem raketen im prinzip aber da gehört halt eben auch ein bisschen da braucht man andere sensoren da muss man ein bisschen wissen wie das mit dem schub funktioniert also da ist.
War das sozusagen auch ihre rolle bei dem bremen seid bei diesem.
Bei bremse war das ursprünglich mal eine rolle war lage regelung von bremen seid,
bremsen hat dann momentum wählen das ist ein prinzip großer kreisel der den satelliten stabilisierte das hab ich mit aufgebaut habe die algorithmen dafür geschrieben habe die software geschrieben hardware getestet,
und dann eben auch alles zusammengebaut ich war mit mit holger am ende der die waren wir die leitung von von dem satelliten wir waren eigentlich auch nur eine hand voll leute also es war schon ein projekt was so durchaus auch im spacex szene war schnell und,
und mit wenig leuten also von daher ich bin das auch gewöhnt gewesen wir hatten lange lange arbeitstage wir hatten wir haben die mission kontrolle mit drei leuten gemacht,
über ein ganz nah vier vier leute über ein ganzes jahr also es war schon schon ähnlich in den in der intensität als als als basics.
Was war denn das für eine begegnung da also man trifft sich da in so einem lounge worüber redet man denn dann.
Naja irland fragte so ein bisschen halt wenn ich mich recht erinnere was wir machen wo ich herkomme und und
das war's dann im prinzip auch schon da war nicht nicht nicht viel es waren immer das ist ein amateur raketen gewesen die waren ja die sind so was sagen zwei meter drei meter lang so und ich nehme
größte vielleicht vier meter und dann dann starten die halt und die hälfte der staatskanzlei von an haben wir so lachen wesentlichen und die andere hälfte geht halt wirklich gut weg und guckt mal halt dass sie wieder runterkommen ne,
das war halt schon mehr mehr das thema des tages hat was hier abgeht dann halt noch ne.
Und war zu dem zeitpunkt schon klar dass so etwas wie space-x entstehen soll.
Nee ich glaube zu dem zeitpunkt war das nicht klar wo es sicherlich in kopf war und dass er auch schon darauf vorbereitet hatte aber werden darüber gar nicht geredet und dann dem an dem tag das war wirklich nur nur kurz kennenlernen.
Das heißt das war dann sozusagen gleich der nächste punkt ist das thema aufkam.
Das nächste mal hat sich gemeldet hat war im prinzip ich würde mal sagen zwei monate später und auch nicht ganz nicht ganz,
das war schon ein bisschen überraschend für mich hätte ich nicht mit gerechnet aber.
Also er fragte mich dann ob ich interesse hat an einer neuen firma teilzunehmen und ich habe mir das ganze fünf millisekunden lang überlegt und geh ja gesagt,
also ich war auch so in so einem punkt im leben wo man wo man was machen musste und irgendwie mal.
Egal gewesen wer gefragt hätte.
Nee nicht ganz also was mich an bestimmte sachen habe ich an ihren fasziniert zum einen dass er eben das geld hatte und das den den
das auch auf den tisch gestellt hat mir weniger hat gesagt ich habe schon so viel davon packe ich so viel auf den tisch und das fand ich schon mal durchaus bemerkenswert was mich noch mehr beeindruckt hat ist dass er gesagt hat er wird nach los angeles ziehen weil hier das talent ist,
und zwar.
Den vorher gewohnt.
Er hat in palu alte gewohnt also er kam ja von peter,
glaube ich direkt und pepa war ein paar und es ist im prinzip ein silicon valley,
die person die da gedeiht und und aufwachsen und los angeles ist so ein bisschen naja mehr traditioneller eros space und film halt nicht und,
was ich halt auch vorher gelernt habe ist die meisten leute wie zum beispiel auch die sagen okay ich lebe hier ich mache hier eine firma
und ihr kommt alle zu mir ja und und machte das eben umgetreten für mich war das ein zeichen dass er das zum einen ernst meint und zum anderen auch alles dransetzen von seiner seite
und das eben erfolgreich zu machen weil das wäre weniger erfolgreich erfolgreich gewesen wenn er gesagt hätte ihr kommt alle nachhaltig in berlin,
da will ich mal davon ausgehen das war genau das richtige was man machen musste ich hätte mir vielleicht überlegt dass wir zu ziehen aber dann vielleicht fünfzig prozent hätten das nicht gemacht ja,
also das ganze nach los angeles zu legen und zu sagen hier sind die leute die das können und hier sind die leute wo wo wir das die wir brauchen um eine rakete zu bauen das war genau genau das richtige in dem in dem in dem fall.
Und dann war so die ansage der lass mal raketen bauen.
Hatte von anfang an.
Bestimmte sachen waren von anfang an in seinem kopf nicht also zum beispiel maß war war von anfang an dabei und und der ganze der anspruch halt die menschheit multiplayer tat zu machen das war von anfang an auch dabei nicht und.
Also gleich sozusagen die die größte spielkarte die man spielen.
Das ziel das ziel war von vornherein ganz ganz weiter hinten ja und und in der in der praxis haben wir gesagt okay wir brauchen wir bauen eine rakete jetzt die lieber mit wenigen leuten bauen können.
Und,
wir haben halt eine bestimmte triebwerk technologie wir haben kerosin und flüssigen sauerstoff ausgewählt weil wenn man das relativ einfach entwickeln kann relativ also alles alles im endeffekt nicht ganz so leicht und wir hatten auch immer vor,
die sachen soweit wie's geht selber zu machen,
ja also wir hatten nicht vor zum beispiel zu sagen okay wir bestellen den tank hier bei dieser firma und den motor bei dir bei jener firma sondern wir hatten vor wir wollen die sachen bauen wir wollen tatsächlich die schlüsseltechnologien beherrschen und wir werden,
die was das war das dritte ding was ich eigentlich auch fand was er was er absolut richtig erkannt hat wir werden die schwierigen probleme am anfang angehen und nicht nach hinten schieben,
also zum beispiel die triebwerkstechnologien man braucht die motor entwicklung turbinen und so weiter das ist
alles was wir am anfang gemacht haben wir haben in den ersten wochen angefangen versuche mit dem gast generator laufen zu lassen um einfach zu sehen wie der wie das wie das funktioniert und,
von vornherein sozusagen gleich die großen tests die wir brauchen geplant und ausgeführt und nicht irgendwie gesagt lass uns mal erstmal die firma bauen und dann was soll ich sie die couchgarnitur kaufen und dann dann machen wir den den motor nicht das war
so wie man es machen muss macht die schwierigen probleme am anfang,
und tatsächlich haben die auch im nächsten gedauert ja das sind so sachen die dann die dann sozusagen ja im prinzip sind.
Und die anderen sachen die schneller gehen die kann man auch später angehen.
Mit wie vielen leuten wurde daran gearbeitet.
So wir haben am anfang ich weiß noch ich habe am anfang im prinzip halb technisch gearbeitet,
und auch durchaus selber noch und halb als recruiting sozusagen leute versucht zu überreden mitzumachen angerufen was ich halt immer mit meinem adressbuch hatte.
War das überhaupt so groß weil so viel zeit in usa jetzt auch noch nicht verbracht.
Heute hat ein paar jahre ja,
ja ich habe mir passiert das stimmt schon ich hatte ich hatte ein paar leute halt von von meiner arbeit kennen kennengelernt ich habe vor allen dingen also nicht nur bei der firma wo ich gearbeitet habe sondern auch mit anderen firmen zusammengearbeitet ja,
und das hat mir schon ein bisschen mehr exporter sozusagen gegeben ich kannte schon ein paar leute ja und dann ist es halt auch so ich bin halt immer ein sonderfall gewesen ich habe einen komischen namen und dreht mit dem deutschen akzent von daher behalten nicht leute,
im kopf.
Tja der arnold schwarzenegger.
Genau genau das erinnert mich dann auch mal dran.
Deutschland hat ja auch einen ganz guten ruf was so die raketen technik.
Ja und also wie gesagt das war,
halb halb recruiting und halb halb technische arbeitet hat das im prinzip auch gut aufgesetzt er hat,
drei vier,
damals oder weiß passent gehabt und die waren so um die vierzig jahre um wir sind alle im gleichen alter gleiche gleiche gruppe im prinzip und dann hatten wir halt,
unsere aufgabe war halt ein team aufzubauen ja mein team war nix software und ich glaube das war's,
da war noch dabei also fleißig ja das war im prinzip alles was im prinzip ein relativ großes gebiet ne,
heute arbeiten da ich weiß gar nicht genau auf meine hundert leute da drin ist und.
Und das war im prinzip auch genau das richtige für mich weil ich hatte halt auch ich kann ein bisschen software ich kann ein bisschen navionics ich kann kein tor und und ich kann ein bisschen fleisch saftig und und und,
das das war halt mein mein erster job halt,
das department aufzubauen die richtigen leute zu heuern die richtigen sachen anzufangen simulator wir haben einen richtig richtig guten simulator gehabt von anfang an den von dem ich gearbeitet habe und.
Sonst hoffe simulator für alle.
Ja genau im prinzip schneller so ein bisschen lebenserhaltungssystem für die rakete simulierte rakete dazu fliegt ja und du hast halt halt super wichtig für sachen die du nicht testen kannst.
Ja und das war halt so der anfang nicht und es war halt das war im prinzip sehr hektisch sehr viel arbeit und und eine ganz tolle zeit ich beides gleichzeitig.
Wenn man sich dann gleich zu anfang auf die schweren sachen stürzt dann würde ich mir vorstellen ist das ja auch nicht unbedingt von viel erfolg geprägt.
Man muss ein gewisses momentum haben ja und mit dem gewisse dicke haut um um dann eine zurück schlägen zu arbeiten aber auf der anderen seite rückschläge ist eben das einzige was einem so ein bisschen beibringen was man besser machen kann beim nächsten mal.
Eines was was ich mir so dachte was eines meiner probleme war ich hatte mit bremse hat relativ viel erfolg von anfang an,
und dachte dass es leicht ja kein problem und dann als wir halt mit mit falken wann damals das war die erste rakete anfing,
die ersten drei ging schief nicht und das war sowas wo da hatte ich ihn nicht so richtig mit gerechnet,
vor allem die erste da haben wir wirklich intensiv daran gearbeitet jahrelang die rakete zusammengebaut das war so alles was wir sozusagen im kopf hatten war da drin,
bei der staatenlose und nach dreißig sekunden gibt es keinen schub mehr weil irgendwie verbindung aufging und dann alles im motor abgebrannt ist und dann kam sie wieder runter und,
er ist halt unten auf dem boden explodiert und das war schon,
das war schon ein bisschen traumatisch für für phase im prinzip nicht meine frau hat mir gesagt ich habe danach monat nicht mehr mit dir geredet.
Also nicht geredet einfach ja nicht nur mensch nicht mit dir aber und und und das wie viele sind ja wirklich monate und,
und danach hat man sich halt wieder zusammengerauft und dann eben entsprechend die zweite gebaut zweite ging auch schief dann wird die dritte gebaut die dritte ging,
auch schief aber gar fast richtig nicht und dann hatten wir damals die dritte und die vierte zusammengebaut und hatte eigentlich gesagt er ist gut für drei versuche,
und nach der trip nach der dritten rakete halt schief ging hat uns alle halten meeting rum,
gerufen und hat er gesagt okay wir haben noch eine rakete da wir werden ein flugzeug heuern und die rakete runter zu fliegen und wir wollen in vier wochen starten also im prinzip nochmal so ein double down,
manöver und da,
es hat im prinzip glaube ich sieben wochen gedauert werden noch ein paar mehr probleme aber alles was wir zwischen den dritten oder vierten rakete geändert haben weil der zeitpunkt zwischen dem oder motor ausgeht und wo wir die zweite stufe aussetzen ja,
es waren halt statt was weiß ich sowieso konnten doppelt so viel zu kunden ja und das war das was was gefehlt hat und nach ginger arbeiten alles klar okay.
Hat sich denn in dieser phase dieser anfangsphase schon irgendwie.
Aus diesem grundansatz irgendwie schon so eine andere arbeitskultur eingefunden als man sie vielleicht jetzt bei anderen unternehmen findet.
Immer immer immer anders also war immer für mich war es was eine ziemliche umstellung am anfang wir waren immer eine kultur wo halt der,
kommunikation ist am wichtigsten krank zählt überhaupt nicht
und die beste die beste idee gewinnt halt nicht und und talent ist halt ist halt am aus was wir am höchsten schätzen
mit anderen worten wir werden alles tun um zu dem ziel zu kommen und wie wir da hinkommen ist eigentlich nicht so unbedingt so wichtig ja.
Versus wie läuft's normalerweise oder wie.
Naja also zum beispiel wir geben wir haben den ingenieuren oder allen ingenieuren,
wie viel handlungs freiraum gegeben ja wenn es darum geht was zu bestellen bestellen einfacher du hast was was ich bis fünftausend oder zehntausend brauchst als als als limit dann machen wir das auch ja also sozusagen alles getan um leuten
das arbeiten zu erleichtern und schnell zu machen ja ich hatte zum beispiel damals testlabor aufgebaut in eines meiner was ich halt machen wollte ich wollte das
die die geräte also die tamara kammer der vibrations wie heißt das ding.
Wie heißt das auf englisch ja.
Den shaker und dann was weiß ich schock und alles so nebeneinander stellen sodass es eigentlich gar keine ausrede gab man muss testen ja aber das ist so bequem dass da muss man nicht irgendwie rausgehen einen termin machen und dann in einem test haus irgendwie machen ja,
wir hatten alles da und da gab es auch keine diskussion wir brauchen den wahlkampf,
ich meine das ist sowas und investments halt auch teurer teure teure investments und auf jeden fall gesagt klar also wir werden wenn es uns irgendwie hilft das schneller zu machen dann machen wir es auf jeden fall ne und dann halt auch eben eine kultur wo halt kein,
kein einzelzimmer ist alles ist sozusagen in einem großraum wenn man wenn man ein bisschen ruhe braucht dann setzt man sich einen kopfhörer auf,
und alles wie gesagt arbeitet sieht an einem strang streng.
Ich fand das schon durchaus bemerkenswert werden ein test,
test seit damals haben wir immer noch einen mcgregor und am anfang hatten wir halt auch ihren hatten habe ich einen kleinen privaten chat und hat da immer die leute hierher geflogen weil es einfach damit schneller ging zeit ist alles,
nicht nur geld.
Zeit ist alles weil man schon versprechungen gemacht hat weil man schnell zum ergebnis kommen wollte ich mein gewisser hinsicht braucht man ja auch manchmal einfach zeit.
Auch ich meine auch die versprechungen waren sind teilweise auch dazu da um den druck zu machen dass das eben entsprechend auch auch schnell geht ja aber tatsächlich,
wenn man sozusagen für zeit optimiert dann ist die sind die kosten oftmals auch nicht nicht höher als wenn man das sozusagen,
langsamer machen würde und bedächtig er und dann eben entsprechend ausrollen und dann auch dann nochmal sozusagen länger braucht ja es ist so ein bisschen so ein ding zeit ist halt.
Ein bisschen bewegen gas ne also expandiert und und wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel sage okay ihr habt das in einem jahr dann würde das nicht ein jahr dauern es wird halt zwei jahre damit wenn ich sage ihr habt das ein dreiviertel jahr dann würde das eben
durchaus eben anderthalb jahre dauern zum beispiel ja und es gibt einen punkt wo's nicht mehr komprimiert war ist also wo es wo es dann halt lächerliches.
Leute auch nicht mehr komprimiert war sind ich meine man kann ja nicht.
Genau genau.
Beliebige geschwindigkeit jetzt erfordern.
Beziehungsweise sachen gehen auch schief nicht ich meine wir testen sachen und dann dann stellen wir fest nee das war keine gute idee an der motor kann nicht so viel ja oder wir brauchen dieses teil muss irgendwie neu entwickelt werden also es kommt das kommt vor,
keine keine frage da muss man halt eben auch einen großen zeitplan irgendwie im hinterkopf dann dann mit einrechnen.
Wie viel an dieser frühen entwicklung hat sich denn so an etablierten raumfahrt bau,
wissen orientiert also hat man eigentlich so erstmal alles so von der stange genommen und damit weitergearbeitet oder waren eigentlich die ansätze von vornherein schon anders.
Wir haben ich würde mal sagen wir haben immer mischung gemacht aus,
was was ist physikalisch notwendig was macht sinn sozusagen und und das war so
back to basics und auf der anderen seite mal geguckt was es so in der industrie gab die wie die lösung sind und oftmals oftmals haben wir gesagt wir nehmen
dieses teil und jedes teil aber so im groben und ganzen entwickeln wir das neue ja das macht so keinen sinn ja also zum beispiel.
Zum beispiel was weiß ich hatte damals an an computer,
entwickelt beziehungsweise mein team hat das entwickelt und wir hatten im prinzip war noch vor das ist im prinzip ein automatisch automatisierung computer das ist nicht unbedingt was man was man jetzt im im weltraum fliegt,
und da haben wir ein paar teile dazu gekauft,
ich habe das mal die wm genannt also die maschine und und dann haben wir ein paar teile dazu entwickelt ja und dann das sozusagen so eingepackt dass es halt den staat überlebt und
die traditionelle lösung wäre halt gewesen zu einem herrscher dass sie gehen zu sagen ich kaufe vielleicht einen flug computer damit haben wir halt so ein,
bisschen entwicklungsarbeit gehabt aber wir haben wir haben den größten teil dann doch irgendwie aus der industrie anderen industrien zusammen gekauft,
wir haben oftmals einen anderen industrien geschaut,
sie macht automobilindustrie das wir sind die stecker dort was hat die die die die raumfahrt und manchen fällen haben wir gesagt wir müssen das nehmen was die raumfahrt momentan macht zum beispiel was
was hat dich die stecker und so in anderen haben wir eben gesagt wir wir bauen das selber und bauen unseren computer selber.
Also es ist immer so ein mischmasch gewesen aus naja tradition wo sinn macht aber wir haben sehr viel auch auch auch vom grund auf im prinzip entwickelt.
Also vor allen dingen auf die motoren halt die das triebwerk mandy,
das war im prinzip auch unsere entwicklung die komplett auf unseren mist gewachsen ist.
Wie anders als das was sonst so eingesetzt wird ist es.
Bis.
Hat gewisse ähnlichkeiten mit anderen zum beispiel einen pinsel injector und so sachen er hat gab's auch schon früher ja aber dann die die details für den kerosin und und sauerstoff motor ist es halt eben auch was gewesen was ich soweit ich weiß noch nicht viel benutzt wurde ja und
wir sind dann auch immer besser geworden die haben zum beispiel auch dann am anfang,
hatte der motor was weiß ich zweiundzwanzig fünfundzwanzig ventil und am ende hat er eben halt dann immer immer weniger gehabt wie war wie
sachen kombiniert haben die sowieso gleichzeitig geschaltet werden ja also es gehört wir hatten ja wir sind ja mittlerweile in der vierten generation ich habe angefangen mit dem motor der war hat eine eine gesamte sogenannte ablative kammer,
das war im prinzip eine eine brennkammer die war aus phenol harz,
und die konnte man nur einmal benutzen und danach war sie wieder weg und dann haben wir die die nächsten generation wandern halt motoren die hatten kühl
leitungen in den in den kammern und konnten halt eben auch entsprechend länger brennen das braucht man eben auch um halt wiederverwendbar zu sein und.
Wir hatten also schon irgendwie schritte genommen die die das ganze sozusagen realistischer machten was in den zeitraum den wir halt machen wollten.
Also ich würde mal sagen im im groben und ganzen wir haben,
dafür optimiert dass wir das selber bauen können und haben dann die technologien noch erweitert in den späteren jahren.
So würde ich das würde ich das beschreiben und immer sehr optimistisch und immer sehr ehrgeizig mit unseren entwicklungen sind wir da gewesen.
Auch ein bisschen mut zum prototyp.
Mut zur lücke muss vor der tür und auch da mut dazu und auch noch auch risiko auf uns genommen wenn es halt darum ging irgendwas
zu testen und möglicherweise dass es eben nicht dir der sicherste weg ist war war der beste langfristig.
Wo es ja immer sehr offensichtlich ist wie konservativ eigentlich an so den raketenbau rangegangen wird ist so die software und die elektronik
oft fliegt ja nur etwas nach oben was irgendwie schon seit zwanzig jahren noch nicht auseinandergefallen ist wie
wie aktuell ist ein space-x mit elektronik eingestiegen ich habe so den eindruck dass hier relativ viel auch von software getragen ist und man jetzt nicht unbedingt nur mit elektronik von vor zwanzig jahren fliegen kann.
Wir benutzen eigentlich die neueste sachen die es nur gibt ja und mit einer einschränkung ja
man muss ein bisschen darauf achten dass strahlung der elektronik klingt nichts ausmacht früher hatten wir nicht die möglichkeit das zu testen also zum beispiel als ich anfing,
da hatten wir noch nicht diese diese möglichkeit die neu neue komponenten zu testen für für für strahlung und da mussten wir halt ein bisschen nicht immer,
bist du bei technologien nehmen wir wussten das funktionierte aber aber heutzutage wir werden also,
wir haben also schon andere andere herangehensweise wir haben schon die herangehensweise es wird
viel software machen wir entwickeln software weiter wir entwickeln unsere komponenten weiter und wir treiben das im prinzip ständig voran um eben sicherzustellen dass wir da nicht irgendwie ein produkt haben was zwanzig jahre alt ist ja.
Da muss man dazu aber auch sagen dass man das relativ vorsichtig machen muss also änderungen sind tatsächlich ein problem man ändert irgendwie hier was und dann denkt man nicht an alles was sie da sozusagen die an internet konsequentes sind,
und das ist durchaus wert was einem schon mal schon mal rein reißen kann das war mit mit einem der schwierigsten sachen pakete ist relativ,
auf der einen seite sehr relativ komplex von der physik her ja also was vor allen dingen die flüssigkeiten angeht und so sachen auf der anderen seite finde ich die steuerung in der kälte ist eigentlich relativ einfach ich sage dazu immer camp schafft,
weil ja kita hat keine zwei abzweigungen in dem programm
oder relativ wenige die weiß die macht halt was weiß ich brennt den ersten motor für was weiß ich hundert hundert fünfundsiebzig sekunden danach gibt's halt eine sequenz die sitzt die rakete die zweite stufe aus,
das ist alles im prinzip etwas was man relativ leicht machen kann es wird komplizierter wenn man dann auch sachen anfängt zu wiederzuverwenden und dabei noch auf,
schiffen zu landen oder auf dem land zu landen und dann wird's ein bisschen komplizierter aber im prinzip von der software her.
Raketen relativ einfach gestrickt sattel ist erheblich kommt komplexer auch so sachen angeht.
Zumindest was den staat betrifft.
Korrekt die landung sicherlich was was eine gewisse herausforderung ist vor allen dingen für für control ja.
Das heißt,
bei der software wurde dann auch in die vollen gegangen und man hat sehr viel drauf gesetzt in dem moment wo man auf halbwegs moderne elektronik setzt kann man ja dann auch die,
sprechenden vorteile nutzen durch höhere laufgeschwindigkeit oder eben vielleicht auch komplexe berechnung für modelle.
Das ist ein guter punkt weil ich hatte eigentlich immer immer versucht die software-entwicklung so einfach wie möglich zu machen dadurch dass man halt computer hat die nicht irgendwie klein sind,
einfach dass das neueste was halt was er geht und dann was weiß ich was die abrechnungssystem angeht und so weiter und sofort dann auch nichts kompliziertes alles was was was jeder kann sozusagen ja und die was,
die das macht halt eben entsprechend die softwareentwicklung mein fasten das heißt software was normalerweise am längsten auch und am am spätesten eben dran ist kann am schnellsten kann schneller fertig werden das heißt man kann im prinzip schneller fliegen.
Was kommt denn da so zum einsatz.
Also wir haben ein soweit ich weiß ein trainingssystem das immer noch links ist,
also und dann passiert die ganzen publik domain sachen ich glaube das falsche wort,
danke das ist natürlich mittlerweile haben wir unsere eigene version davon ja also von daher ist es nicht mehr ganz das richtige das gleiche ja aber,
am anfang sucht man halt oft die open source und das was halt jeder im prinzip benutzen kann.
Aber das kann man ja nicht komplett jetzt aus open source heran nehmen da muss ja auch noch eine ganze menge eigenes entwickelt werden um sozusagen letzten endes da eine funktionierende rakete hinzu.
Kam wie die rakete sozusagen gesteuert wird das aber so so dramatisch ist auch nicht werden also am anfang hatten wir im prinzip einen später noch einen zweiten software ingenieur der daran gearbeitet hat,
das war's es waren zwei leute zu dem zeitpunkt wo wir vielleicht drei wo wir dann geflogen sind nicht heute ist die software abteilung wesentlich größer macht aber auch wesentlich mehr nicht.
Also am anfang war das wirklich versucht haben wir wirklich versucht das ganze simpel zu halten und und mit zu wenig aufwand wie möglich am am am weitesten zu kommen.
Ist jetzt natürlich generell so dass,
problem wenn man jetzt so durchstartet und in so einem start-up modus ist und sagt okay jetzt probieren wir mal alles mal selber aus und erstmal ein paar,
hatte probleme lösen damit wir auch selber ein gefühl dafür haben es kann jetzt hier vorangehen und lohnt sich jetzt auch andere leute dazu zu holen die jetzt quasi schon mal so auf etwas aufsetzen können und den dann nicht,
später irgendwie der teppich unterm boden weggezogen wird so nach dem motto ja sorry unser grundansatz hat nicht funktioniert wir müssen jetzt nochmal komplett von vorne anfangen so oder so in dem moment wo mehr,
zeug dazu kommt und mehr leute dran arbeiten geht ja auch die komplexität meistens durch,
die decke die komplexität entweder in der zusammenarbeit oder die komplexität auch einfach in der summe aller technischen komponenten der interdependenz der zusammenhänge der abhängigkeiten der einzelnen dinge inwiefern ist der blick auf diese sich,
eigenständig weiter entwickelnde komplexität hier teil der philosophie gewesen hatten prüft man das.
Ich würde mal sagen die die der ansatz war am anfang wir werden das mit so wenig leuten wie möglich,
und mit so offener kommunikation wie wie möglich versuchen weil das stimmt tatsächlich je mehr leute halt daran arbeiten wenn fünfhundert leute,
an so einem projekt arbeiten ist das einfach schwieriger als wenn da zweihundert leute daran arbeiten oder,
eigentlich sagen sollen fünftausend gegenüber zweihundert ja wir waren ungefähr als der erste start.
Passierte war mir vielleicht zweihundertfünfzig oder so als der erste erfolgreiche war waren wir vielleicht,
vierhundert irgend sowas nimmt reha rum ich meine ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich hab damals viel zeit im am startplatz verbraucht das war in den,
in den marshall islands das ist in der nähe nähe quattro und eine amerikanische amy base ziemlich weit draußen im wasser,
und habe eigentlich nicht so richtig viel mitgekriegt was also in den engel ist oder auch ein horst,
mit der mit der firma passiert wir waren wirklich nur darauf fokussiert die die unfall quark hermann zu starten und dann.
Ich habe relativ relativ viel viel zeit da unten zugebracht und dann kann man halt mal wieder nach hause und hat halt was weiß ich,
leute gesehen die vorher gesehen hat heute heute heute geht mir jetzt eigentlich fast nur noch so aber was passiert wenn die firma wächst,
ist dass man halt spezialisten hat,
und die spezialisten werden arbeiten ein bisschen so in sehr sehr in die tiefe aber oftmals nicht sehr breit und da geht ein bisschen was verloren wenn sowas passiert man man man gewinnt auf der einen seite an
an qualität würde ich mal sagen auf der anderen seite muss man höllisch aufpassen dass es auch entsprechend kommuniziert werden dass da nicht was verloren geht war leute nicht miteinander reden,
also das ist so ein sehr dreckig trick dreckigsten sachen was man halt bei einer großen firma sicherstellen muss dass man alle an einem in einem,
eine richtung arbeitet muss die ganzen sagte man ist die ganzen sektoren sozusagen auch in die gleiche richtung zeigen von den leuten nicht und nicht dass du so einige dabei sind die so so rechts und links davon sind ja weil das macht sie auch entsprechend nicht so effektiv.
Gibt es denn dann jemand der sich genau um die beobachtung von so etwas kümmert oder ist das eigentlich etwas was man im,
im team sich erhalten muss weil zwangsläufig wenn man dann immer mehr erfolge hatte und merkt so nah läuft doch so dann tendiert man ja auch schnell dazu zu sagen so.
Passt schon hat der hat ja schon ist schon immer gut gegangen und man verliert vielleicht so dieses momentum wo man wo man schnell erkennt okay wir sind jetzt hier auf dem weg in so einem land.
Also ich würde mal sagen das ist im prinzip der job der vip sowas ist am zug zu erkennen und dann auch entsprechend vorzubringen zu sagen hey wir haben hier ein,
problem wo wir das bauen und das bauen das passt nicht so richtig zusammen oder wir müssen uns mal hinsetzen und sicherstellen dass wir das auch genau abgleichen können,
wir hatten im prinzip wir haben über die wöchentliche meetings mit elon wo wir diese sachen durchbrechen und wo alle unsere unsere vorschläge auch was verbauen wie wir bauen vorlegen und dabei kommen halt oftmals auch sachen raus die,
nochmal zurück müssen tore gibt's ja eigentlich,
gibt es ja eigentlich nicht mehr aber aber bitte doch noch so gesagt nicht,
combo schon auch vor dass das aber nochmal und zurückzugehen auf auf von wegen erfolg also wir hatten mit falken eins auch erfolg am am ende ja und dann haben wir aber gleichzeitig angefangen falken nein zu bauen weil wir,
auch von der von der nase dann den auftrag bekommen hatten mit dragan die station zu versorgen ja und,
ich würde mal sagen das ging es ging da war immer so eine so eine so ein element dabei wo wir sachen lernen konnten ja also wo sachen eben nicht so ganz richtig gingen.
Zum beispiel auch die sachen die wir dann halt gemacht haben mit den landungen da waren die ersten
wir sagen das erste dutzend landung waren eigentlich alle alle etwas was schief ging in dem sinne ja und auch mit fakten mit falken eins hatte hat mir schon eigentlich wollten wir damit schon landen werden eigentlich einen falschen an bord,
in der ersten stufe den haben natürlich nie nie so richtig einsetzen können ja die erste stufe ist immer verglüht und an der wind war nie was von übrig aber wir haben halt,
trotzdem immer versucht da diese diese wiederverwendbare zeit von anfang an mit mit zu testen.
Und am ende haben wir halt eingesehen weil das eben auch nicht klappt und es war durchaus auch ein fehlschlag sozusagen intern ja,
vielleicht nicht von der von außen von außen gesehen aber intern wurden wir halt raketen wieder benutzen und landen ja und da muss man halt eben hinsetzen und dann nochmal
ein bisschen mehr daran arbeiten wie wir die raketen jetzt durch die atmosphäre kriegen oder über die erste stufe durch die atmosphäre kriegen wie wir sie anlanden ab war,
statt fallschirm haben wir dann am ende mit mit den triebwerken vorgeschlagene verlangen und unsere sachen also,
da war immer arbeit,
notwendig und haben wir immer noch weitergearbeitet von außen sah das vielleicht nicht so aus weil von außen haben wir gesehen haben hat leute gesehen die starten starten satelliten und dann später auch eben dragon aber
von von innen weil er halt immer noch arbeit an den an der wiederverwendbare zeit.
Als ich das richtig verstehe es war jetzt auch in dieser nach außen hin schon relativ erfolgreich strahlenden phase genug fehl da.
Genau genau.
Dass man sich noch nicht so weit eingedickt hat dass man denkt man kriegt jetzt irgendwie alles hin aber das muss ja nicht unbedingt ewig so bleiben also es,
können wir schon vorstellen dass das so ein strukturelles problem ist war ja dann mehr leute da sind mehr konkurrenz dann will man irgendwie auch seinen bereich irgendwie gut dastehen haben ist ein ganz mensch
ganz menschliche natur sozusagen da muss ja dann so ein unternehmen so eine struktur so eine organisation eigentlich immer entgegenwirken und sagen
ja nie fehler sind auch teil der methode und du darfst auch und du musst in gewisser hinsicht sogar fehler machen und nur weil jetzt dein ansatz irgendwo,
zu nichts geführt hat,
ist ja diese erkenntnis nicht uninteressant also wie das ja generell in der wissenschaft auch ist man sagt na ja okay wir haben zwar jetzt hier nur herausgefunden dass es so nicht geht aber das ist ja auch an sich ein wert.
Ja man muss man muss dabei auch ein bisschen aufpassen ich meine offensichtlich die die die hauptperson die wir halt haben die darf darf nie fehlen dabei gefährdet sein und das ist eben auch ein bisschen schwierig wir hatten halt lange zeit
die haupt mission gut abgearbeitet würde ich mal sagen und dann haben wir bei der landung eben entsprechend die die versuche durchgeführt ja was halt völlig separat ist von von dem von der haupt von und das war tatsächlich ein guter ansatz
ein ansatz finde ich der der der wesentlich besser als das was andere organisation dabei machen wir konnten halt unsere haupt mission durchführen und da,
zweite stufe ist weg und die erste stufe macht jetzt eben ihre manöver um dann entsprechend zu landen und,
wenn das mal schief ging dann ging das eben schief ja aber war hat eben auch nicht die haut mission gefährdet hat wird auch nie irgendwie so so so aufgefasst dass das irgendwie was damit zu tun hat,
im gegensatz dazu wir haben irgendwann mal auch unsere gesamten landungen die schief ging,
veröffentlicht als ein youtube-video glaube lernt rocket heißt das,
schaut euch das durchaus komisch ja schon ein bisschen weh wenn ich das sehe ich war da waren wirklich einige da war ein wirklich hart hart breaking weil ihrer kita landet und dann so langsam in den nächsten zehn sekunden einfach umfeld.
Aber ich glaube dass es in der außendarstellung auch eine sehr wertvolle geschichte gewesen weil man sich einerseits kommt glaube ich sowieso mal ganz gut rüber wenn man,
wenn man so das gefühl hat okay die nehmen sich selber jetzt nicht zu ernst so auf der anderen seite auch eben ganz konkret eben diese,
ich sag mal so ganz zu scheitern als als als chance ja also dass man sozusagen mit fehlern bewusst umgeht und und sie so also ich war glaube ich
bei der ersten landung wir können ja vielleicht gleich nochmal konkrete auch auf die ganze raketen entwicklung kommen aber ich weiß noch als so das,
erstmal alle so wartet so nah hat's geklappt so und dann gab es zu dem zeitpunkt ja noch kein video davon was war ja diese landung auf dem.
Das video ist immer ausgegangen genau wenn ihr rakete gelandet ist.
Durch die vibration weil es.
Durch die vibration genau weil die.
Das aufzunehmen.
Ja das ist ein schlüssel auf dem auf dem auf dem schiff halt ne,
auf dem schiff und wenn die halt landet dann ging es halt eine weile aus dann stand da irgendwas drauf ich weiß nicht genau was es war im sinne von bitte warten ja und dann das bild wieder da stand die kette und dieser sagte natürlich da habt ihr jetzt nicht gemacht oder.
Und ich glaube tatsächlich die letzte landung vor ein paar tagen auf ein jones war die erste wo das video nicht ausgegangen ist dass sie mir richtig auf.
War das auch eine entwicklung für sich ist das technisch überhaupt hinzubekommen was was ich meine ist als es,
als dann sozusagen dann diese diese fehler nachgereicht waren glaube ich der ilona das einfach nur so ganz,
zum kleinen lustigen kommentar so ja hat nicht funktioniert hier ist explodiert nächste mal wird's besser und das das fand ich irgendwie ganz
ganz gut weil gerade wenn man sich anschaut wie auch die lisa mit ihren oder ariane spaß und mit ihren letzten federn doch,
arge schwierigkeiten hatte auf einmal in diesem modus wiederzukommen nachdem er auch zwanzig jahre lang wirklich extrem gut gelaufen ist ja merkt man dass hier doch ein anderer geist dahinter war.
Ja ich meine was was was wichtiges danach das halt immer,
muss immer klar sein dass wir wir wir untersuchen das sehr sorgfältig danach also mein job ist unter anderem auch so sachen hat entsprechend zu untersuchen und mittlerweile ist mein job nicht,
und und herauszufinden was falsch gewesen ist und dann machen wir auch dementsprechend die korrekturen nicht und wir brauchen wir brauchen oftmals monate dafür bis wir das wirklich alles aus haben und die richtigen die richtigen korrekten haben,
und das reinsprechen durchsetzen das ist also nicht da ist ein bisschen was salopp ist dran nach außen hin ja aber nach innen nach innen wird das durchaus ist das durchaus ernst,
sitzen wir also noch über wochen über daten und und gehen dadurch um sicherzustellen dass da nichts,
nichts schiefgehen kann bei der nächsten und auch nichts schiefgehen kann später nochmal.
Ich wollte auch gar nichts das so darstellen dass das irgendwie den eindruck hatte dass es nachlässig.
Ja
Behandelt wird sondern dass man dass man einfach anders damit umgeht also dass man sozusagen dass das ein preis und sagt so ja das kann halt passieren aber das ist halt an sich,
kann man das ja sozusagen auch einfach als fundgrube neue erkenntnisse werden was ist ja letzten endes auch ist.
Genau und da muss man halt wie gesagt sehr unterscheiden von das ist die hauptperson dass sie glattlaufen dass da alles okay ist und dass das eben der teil ist nur wo man halt noch dran entwickelt die die die wiederverwendbar
und das nicht mal ein anderes beispiel ist halt nicht nur die erste stufe die landung sondern eben auch die fairrank diese die die schreibt mir das ist im prinzip die.
Die umschließung der pilot.
Genau die hülle von der leute nicht das war sie wollten die haben halt den vorteil dass sie relativ leicht sind oder nicht große fläche haben damit kann man sich durch die atmosphäre bringen relativ,
einfach in theorie und das haben wir halt von anfang an auch probiert und das war nicht ganz einfach am anfang aber irgendwann haben wir sie halt entsprechend auch durch die atmosphäre durchgebracht sehr faszinierend übrigens dass ein,
ich glaube ein video draußen wie die durch die atmosphäre gehen das ist absolut faszinierend und.
Gesehen was ist daran.
Na das hat so diese diese blaue die luft die da so drum herum geht ja und und das ganze ist halt richtig wieder eintritt im prinzip mit einem halben ferien da ist nichts dran da ist irgendwie ein bisschen hitzeschild auf der auf der rückseite ja
aber es ist nicht viel das funktioniert größtenteils einfach mal die fläche so groß ist.
Und dann öffnet sich da der fallschirm und dann hatten wir halt auch eine lange zeit geplant mit einem boot und ein riesiges netz die aufzufangen was auch ein bisschen verrückt aussah und es hat auch,
einige male gedauert bis wir das nicht beim letzten mal beim vorletzten mal tatsächlich auch geschafft haben,
halt das feeling auf dem boot landet und das war jetzt das video ist auch da das ist nachts nachtvideo das sieht das hier eindeutig falsch ausfindig
wie schwierig zu erklären aber es ist echt das video von der ton aufgenommen und
tatsächlich ist so wie das ferien gelandet ist.
Und diese fairrank sind jetzt glaube ich wenn ich das richtig sehe letzte woche beim letzten start auch das erste mal zum zweiten mal zum einsatz.
Genau das schwierig wurde wiederverwendet durchaus auch ein toller teure komponente und wieder zu verwenden macht halt auch eben sind ne ja.
Ich würde jetzt ganz gerne mal so ein bisschen nochmal auf die rakete,
selber kommen und die entwicklung was was sie sozusagen dann alles wovon sie beeinflusst wurde und wie dieser ablauf gehen also das erste projekt weil die falkon.
Packen waren ja.
Das war sozusagen erstmal der versuch überhaupt zu beweisen wir kriegen hier überhaupt irgendwas.
Im endeffekt ja am anfang war das nicht ganz so ich glaube er macht den anfang hat mir gedacht wir können tatsächlich damit am markt finden und dass eben auch entsprechend weiterbauen am ende,
haben wir gesehen dass wir den markt wahrscheinlich der markt nicht groß ist einfach,
das war eine größere rakete brauchen um eben entsprechend in den markt den hauptmarkt sozusagen einzubrechen.
Eine größere als die falkon eins.
Großer packen eins war im prinzip noch erklärte wo man die arme noch drumrum kriegen konnte ja so war das irgendwie gedacht,
wirklich so die arme ausbreiten das ist ungefähr so groß wie der durchmesser der rakete ist halt ne und das war etwas was am anfang,
bauen konnten relativ günstig relativ günstige entwicklung war gemein war das gleiche triebwerk das heißt wir konnten das triebwerk wiederverwenden.
War jetzt auch durchaus schon mit neuen motoren am am an der ersten stufe war durchaus schon eine größere rakete die halt entsprechend was ich fünfzehn tonnen zwanzig tonnen in in die erdnahen umlaufbahn schicken kann,
also unter anderem eben auch dragon dragan ist halt eben auch das versorgungsschiff für die für die im moment.
Und das war eigentlich da wo der markt ist da da wo man im prinzip als firma auch entsprechend geld machen kann.
Und wir hatten das angefangen als wir noch glaube ich habe angefangen mit falkenstein als wir noch nicht mal geflogen sind mit falken norden,
ich hab sehr sehr optimistisch in unseren zeitplan gewesen,
und zu dem zeitpunkt wo also falken wandern erfolgreich war war falken neun also auch schon im bau in und in der entwicklung hat viele teile von entwickelt oder benutzt am,
hat aber auf der anderen seite auch sachen die wir über falcons entwickelt hatten übernommen zum beispiel wir hatten immer jeder motor hatte immer einen eigenen computer,
von daher der computer wusste das ist mein motor ja und ich rede mit dem flug mit dem mit dem hauptcomputer über den über den internet sozusagen und und die sachen hatten sich nicht verändert das war durchaus.
Plug and play gewisser hinsicht ja andere sachen waren waren halt neu wir mussten jetzt tanks bauen die waren zwölf füße sind vier meter nicht,
drei ja das war erheblich schwieriger sowas zu bauen wir hatten neue wir hatten damals auch umgezogen von von zugrunde von der kleinen kleinen,
dein bürogebäude sozusagen mit dem hänger dran sind da jetzt einen riesigen hannah eingezogen das war eine firma die ursprünglich mal für für die sieben vier sieben teile gebaut haben wir die das gebäude übernommen hat,
fünfzigtausend fünftausend quadratmeter glaube ich nicht täusche da hatte millionen fünfzehntausend quadratmeter,
ist das schon groß gebäude und hier wir waren ein paar hundert leute am anfang das gebäude fall her
da waren wirklich nur in einer ecke waren halt die die großen dann haben wir die große weite halle wo man fast mit dem fahrrad mit dem fahrrad hingefahren ist weil es so weit war und das war halt,
wo wir dann halt fragen nein entwickelt haben und angefangen hatten heute heute kann man in der halle das kann man nicht mehr sehen ist voll da ist das kaum noch platz.
Die falker also um das vielleicht auch mal für die leute die das nicht so genau verfolgen klarzumachen falken war halt die erste rakete und hatte im prinzip auch nur ein einziges triebwerk dieses merlin triebwerk.
Am eintritt in der zweiten stufe desto.
Also zwei stufe ich aber quasi so untereinander und nacheinander geschaltet vor allem.
Genau und und hatte auch eine nutzlast von ungefähr fünfhundert pfund tausend freund irgendwie sowas hinterher also dann was weiß ich fünfhundert kilo und irgendwie noch ein bisschen mehr ja und wir hatten auch in in den marshall islands gestartet,
das ist durchaus wichtig marcel,
islands hatten wir gewählt weil wir hatten schwierigkeiten mit den es gibt zwei zwei startplätze usa es gibt werneburg und es gibt und wenn man da ist dann ist man halt muss man halt mit der
mit den airforce sozusagen die sicherheitsbestimmung der airforce einfüllen erfüllen man muss bestimmte,
prozesse halt was weiß ich zur sicherheit entsprechend auch nachkommen und das ist halt eben auch ein bisschen overhead für eine entwicklung und,
unten in den marcel eines sagen wir mal schleien zwar eigentlich war die idee das war toll es ist quatsch,
da war halt nur wasser drum herum und die sicherheitsbestimmung war dementsprechend auch ein bisschen bisschen locker würde ich mal sagen und,
einfach zu erfüllen das war eigentlich für uns der bessere platz eine rakete zu entwickeln der nachteil war es war achttausend meilen,
nicht ganz zweieinhalb fünftausend malen glaube ich von von weg,
schwer hinzukommen und und in der mitte vom ozean und sehr weit weg vom nächsten radio check ist ja auch nicht mehr gibt aber.
War halt ein bisschen logistisch eine herausforderung und war eigentlich auf lange frist auch nicht durchhalten aber war zum würde ich mal sagen,
lernen und und und entwickeln der richtige platz weil das war so ein bisschen außerhalb von allem was.
So mitten im pazifik da ist ja sozusagen eigentlich nicht nicht viel drum herum.
Genau das wasser drum.
Kilometer fliegen bis bis überhaupt irgendwas kommt.
Genau deswegen ist auch relativ wenig darüber bekannt und wenn wir das gleiche in in nürnberg oder in cape gemacht hätten,
hätten alle leute gesehen wie die raketen wieder runterkommen und es hätte wesentlich mehr aufmerksamkeit bekommen und das ganze wäre also wahrscheinlich schwieriger geworden finde ich ja so konnten wir das halt
alles entwickeln und dann mit der falke nein konnten wir das nicht mehr machen weil das war einfach ihre kinder war zu groß für für für quatsch,
tatsächlich was wir nicht machen konnten wir konnten nicht die nutzlasten,
die satelliten auf der startbahn landen ich darf man mal zu kurz dafür die landebahn der flughafen.
Und das war halt so das hauptproblem deswegen sind wir halt drübergezogen nach karneval.
Nachdem es dann irgendwie funktioniert vielleicht nochmal kurz bei der falk zu bleiben also das war sozusagen eigentlich eine rakete kann man eigentlich sagen also.
Heute von aus heutiger sicht stimmt das als damaliger sicht war das eigentlich nicht so geplant wir wollten eigentlich schon produkt haben was er dann auch weiterentwickeln und und.
Für kleine nutzlasten.
Genau aber wir fahren auch um ganz ehrlich zu sein ich glaube da waren wir ein bisschen bisschen naiv dass der markt einfach so groß ist und das weiter zu fördern das war nicht da.
Deswegen gab es dann die entscheidung okay bauen wir doch einfach neun von diesem.
Genau.
Da rein das heißt ich glaube anfangs war das so eine quadratische ausrichtung und später wurde dann quasi eine.
Genau und dann später ein in die mitte im kreis da drum also überhaupt wurde dann quasi mit der geburt der falke neun eigentlich von rakete zu rakete also keine war bisher so wie die davor.
Ja das stimmt glaube ich nicht ganz also wir.
Bis jetzt vor kurzem.
Da sind immer kleinigkeiten die ein bisschen anders hin zum teil sind die ist auch die nutzlast ist natürlich immer anders nicht aber,
die großen sprünge das waren schon schon bewusste,
upgrades zum beispiel was weiß ich wir hatten mit flug einundzwanzig haben wir dann angefangen sauerstoff und kerosin zu kühlen,
kühler noch kühler zwar sowieso schon ist ja und eben auch entsprechend die lande beine benutzen und so sachen das ist alles was wir was wir als blog upgrades im prinzip bezeichnen ganz verschiedene version mittlerweile ist es sehr verwirrend
und und eigentlich auch naja was so wichtig ist wie viel wie viel version wir davon hatten im endeffekt aber,
wir haben schon reicht das war am anfang waren da mehr mehr mehr änderungen und am am ende also jetzt im moment sind da also relativ wenig manchmal auch gar keine keine nennenswerten änderungen.
Aber trotzdem war es auch am anfang klar dass es hier damit nicht fertig sondern es müssen halt verbesserungen.
Ja ja klar genau.
Herbeigeführt werden erstmal war man natürlich froh dass das ding überhaupt gleich am anfang gestartet ist also da da hat er dann.
Durchaus bemerkenswert das war bemerkenswert fand ich auch und dann haben wir halt oft festgestellt was weiß ich die erste stufe verbrennt in der atmosphäre da müssen wir was machen was weiß ich wie können wir mehr leistungen rausholen wenn wir,
mit druck im triebwerk haben und so sachen haben wir langsam von rakete zu rakete ein upgrade gemacht.
Und es wird aber auch von anfang an mit ordentlicher pilot geflogen also es gab keine weiteren test sondern es wurde tatsächlich wirklich zeug ins all gebracht.
Ja die ersten fünf waren im prinzip alles dragon und manches also wo dragon geflogen sind und erst später fing dann an mit dem faserring das war glaube ich flug sechs.
Also dragon ist die versorgungskasse die auch in die andockt.
Genau genau genau das ist eine kapsel ja und das cargos chef sozusagen und mit flug sechs haben wir das erste mal ein gegenstand satelliten gestartet in dem fall auch ein hier von von dsds,
auch europäische firma und.
Das war das erste mal dass wir hatten ferien hatten dass wir auch einen zweiten das zweite mal in dem fall gezündet hatten und so weiter also da waren einige sachen dabei die neu waren ja ich muss das glaube ich zurücknehmen ich glaube flug fünf hat er auch schon satelliten täuscher.
Für fünf hatte kassel oder so das waren.
Yourope war der sechste flug tatsächlich war der siebte.
Ja genau okay dann ja also am main verschoben ja war der erste satellit aber war winzig also,
winzige moderation es war vielleicht was weiß ich,
da kann man auch die arme drumrum kriegen wieder nicht und und was wir danach geflogen sind für für das war ein entsprechenden ein großer nachrichtensender da muss man schon schon kran führen nicht das kann man nicht so einfach die rakete anbauen.
Und da war halt zum beispiel auch ein upgrade da haben wir das erste mal halt feelings benutzt und,
dann haben wir dann einen zweiten start gemacht das braucht man da man stationäre satelliten hochschickt ein ein zuerst beim brennt man das triebwerk sozusagen um in orte zu kommen beim zweiten mal am mercator schiebt man das,
gerade litten dann sozusagen im abo abo um höher auf die auf die bio transfer orban höhe von sechsunddreißigtausend oder so.
Kilometern und was man halt alles dinge die waren das erste mal und dann auch neu für uns,
das war da waren dann schon immer wenn man so sachen macht dann stellt man fest ja wir sollten vielleicht noch hier was machen daraus machen temperatur hat ein problem ist ein problem wir brauchen mehr polierung also kleinigkeiten die dann dementsprechend noch,
und verbessert werden das kommt das kommt also durchaus vor ins hauptgänge.
Der erste erfolgreiche start der vollkommen neun war ja im juni zwanzig zehn das heißt hat eigentlich mal,
nur acht jahre gedauert bis man von von dem paar zeitpunkt wo man so rumstanden und sich das weltraum firma war ja mal ganz geile idee.
Was mit raketen.
Mal was mach doch mal was mit raketen bis da fliegt dann halt auch schon was das ist ja eigentlich ein enormer speed.
Wie kommt das irgendwie langsam vor ich weiß auch nicht genau warum ich bin da schon irgendwie so ich bin da schon so drin das hier irgendwie acht jahre so lange.
Überlegen was ich in den acht jahren gemacht.
Solange das gedauert unglaublich gut es hat acht jahre gedauert weil wir auch noch eine andere kita entwickelt haben zuerst nicht,
und das ist eben auch noch das mit diesen zwei schritten man hätte ich glaube trotzdem war schneller im ernstfall kann nein zu entwickeln als vater nein zu entwickeln wenn wir die sachen gelernt hat dann frage nein ich glaube dann wäre uns das geld ausgegangen,
wenn man so eine große rakete hat jedes dreimal in sand zu setzen das ist schon irgendwie das kostet halt doch eine ganze ecke mehr geld ja also der der ansatz den kleinen rakete zuerst und dann noch eine große um zu springen finde ich war gut.
Und und da hat sich auch hat sich auch bis basics sehr gut bewährt ob das jetzt immer das gleiche sein muss dass das weiß ich nicht es geht wahrscheinlich auch anders.
Mittlerweile sind es ich muss mal kurz hier mal nachschauen das war jetzt letzte woche der fünfundsiebzigste start.
Glaube dass war ja ich glaube glaube die zählung ist siebenundsiebzig war wir noch falken heavy dabeihaben wir müssten drei staat von fabian heavy dabei sein.
Das kann sein.
Ja ich verliere mittlerweile auch ein bisschen die übersicht.
Die werden hier nochmal separat gezählt also genau also es sind sozusagen die drei heavy achtundsiebzig wenn man die heavy jetzt noch mit dazu zählen.
Ja dann sind es fünfundsiebzig nein ja.
Das ist ja schon ist ja schon richtig fett also ich meine das ist jetzt sozusagen auch im vergleich gibt es jetzt glaube ich nichts anderes was soviel abtippen also so.
Atlas sojus glaube ich haben ähnliche zahlen aber wir sind durchaus in der klasse,
das ist schon durchaus für mich auch für mich war das ein bisschen abenteuer am anfang ja und aus dem abenteuer ist halt im prinzip eine firma geworden die heutzutage die meisten satelliten in der welt startet,
das ist schon schon ziemlich verrückt.
Und nicht nur das dabei auch finde ich immer noch am besten aussieht also das können wir vielleicht gleich noch dazu also insbesondere dieser landung aspekt der hat ja auch.
Noch was anderes hinzugefügt ich würde sagen.
Okay space-x ist in der lage eine rakete zu starten das nimmt man so zur kenntnis und so sieht aber im wesentlichen genauso aus wie alle anderen raketen auch macht irgendwie knallbunt viel rauch fliegt hoch ist weg es war es als dann aber diese sache mit dieser landung,
kam und man sich auch so langsam ran tastete und es halt mehrere falls gab da habe ich so das gefühl gehabt,
weil auf einmal was weiß ich man war irgendwie mit freunden zusammen und dann kann man mal so ja das ding startet gleich die wollen irgendwie landen,
und dann habe ich erstmal so dieses gefühl gehabt in meinem leben wo ich mir dachte so hat so ein bisschen was von mondlandung ist jetzt vielleicht nicht ganz so
der totale über knaller aber wenn man sich so ein bisschen mit raumfahrt beschäftigt aber auch eben darüber hinaus hat er das sozusagen so eine wirkung so ein first so ein so ein so ein etwas ist noch nie gemacht worden
und dann sah man es halt ein paar mal scheitern aber jedes jeder weitere versuch wurde dann eigentlich immer noch mehr beobachtet und als es dann irgendwie geklappt hat
war das wirklich enorm ich will überhaupt nicht vorstellen was da im hauptquartier los gewesen ist beziehungsweise man hat das ja so.
Man sieht das ja ein bisschen christian bisschen.
So aus der übertragung schon gemerkt es ist natürlich so dass amerikaner ohnehin dazu tendieren alles immer extrem zu zelebrieren deswegen teile ich das dann immer gleich mal durch drei aber dann blieb dann irgendwie dann doch nochmal genug
über weil man halt einfach merkt wieso ja die nicht nur last von den schultern viel soll sich einfach auch so diese dieser moment einfach nochmal
durch.
Für mich ist es so ein bisschen so also ich meine ich als apollo,
elf gelandet das war sechs jahre alt nicht und von daher fand ich das sehr ungerecht im nachhinein weil ich konnte da nicht mitarbeiten.
Und dann so ein bisschen diese diese diese zweite generation so wir wollen auch unsere follower haben und das hat ein bisschen was damit zu tun.
Und und,
das ist nochmal ein entstanden ist und das ist auch so ein so ein medienhit ist und so von leuten gesehen wird also das finde ich schon auf der einen seite hängt das auch damit zusammen dass
wird es halt auch teil nicht dass die landung spannend sind und dass wir immer auch wir zeigen es eben auch wenn's mal schief geht nicht und,
und zum anderen ist es eben auch was was wir werden werden ja lange überlegt also wir hatten immer diese diese berichterstattung dabei und da ist so richtig so ein ding draus geworden dass es hat seine eigenen form angenommen wie jetzt mit den mit diesen moderatoren und
und wir haben halt auf der einen seite dann sozusagen die jüngeren jedes sozusagen begeistert kommentieren dann ist da noch noch innsbrucker der das der das ein bisschen bisschen klassischer auch sozusagen vorbringen und ein paar paar technische details auch noch,
zu erwähnt also das ganze hat schon so eine form angenommen die ist durchaus younique in dem sinne und und und leute leute mögen als sie sehen dass sie sind die
dieser dieser youtube dinger die sind,
oftmals eine millionen zuschauer oder klickst halt nicht entsprechend was habt ihr wirklich zu ende sehen aber aber zumindest genügend leute um um das schon schon durchaus erstaunlich und was ich auch das bekannt war aber wir haben zum beispiel für die demo mission letzten,
also in diesem jahr im märz wo wir halt die erste dragon zwei kapsel zur station geschickt haben.
Fertig und kam wieder zurück und da gab's dann die berichterstattung die haben wir mit nase zusammen gemacht das war nicht immer ganz einfach und das war auch durchaus mal so ein bisschen so ein kleines kontrastprogramm da hat nasa und spacex von amy vögel gekriegt.
Und das finde ich eigentlich auch schon ziemlich bizarr und und und ungewöhnlich und,
nase kam dann auch von so einem meeting und haben halt den mitgebracht und dann habe ich heute nämlich auch genommen und mein foto gemacht nicht in meiner familie gedankt.
Das war jetzt für den start der falko und heavy.
Das war für den nächsten fragen hey das war die falsche nein die die crew für den ersten flug das land weil sogenannte demo wann flug ja war im märz anfang märz.
Und die haben halt ein bisschen größeres programm gemacht aber eben auch so mit den elementen von spacex da war mir auch klar dass das irgendwie was ist was halt wirklich,
na ja es hat durchaus die die verändert durchaus an apollo auch in dem fall nicht an die berichterstattung und so,
weil tatsächlich haben ich weiß gar nicht ob das der pullover oder davor aber ich hatte das schon in einem anderen film nicht mehr gesehen da haben die auch drei dafür bekommen für die für die berichterstattung entsprechend nicht und das haben wir jetzt auch.
Unerwartet ja naja okay also ich denke das ist auch ein verdienst denke ich von von space-x das ist
doch dazu beiträgt so die begeisterung für raumfahrt wieder zurückzubringen die doch wie ich bin hier in vielen gesprächen hier bei raumfahrt immer wieder feststellen durfte
so gefühlt ein wenig verloren gegangen ist weil es einerseits natürlich die großen leistungen irgendwie mittlerweile eingepreist sind so ja mond waren wir schon das ist ja altes zeug seitdem hat sich ja nicht mehr viel getan und jetzt jetzt kribbelt's wieder so ein bisschen,
das ganze kriegst du einen ganz anderen lack auf einmal jetzt würde ich ganz gerne mal so ein.
So ein lounge und vor allem so eine landung mal ein bisschen zeitlich mal
durchmarschieren das hatte ich so ein staat ist natürlich next überhaupt so eine mission ist natürlich extrem komplizierte geschichte da könnte man sich jetzt wahrscheinlich fünf tage drüber unterhalten was dort alles so zu laufen ist aber vielleicht mal so unter diesem gesichtspunkt wo auch
die falken neun und die ganze moderne entwicklung die da reingefallen ist
sich sozusagen auch bewährt hat oder wo man bestimmte entwicklungen vielleicht auch nochmal gut ablesen kann weil sich ja auch,
immer gerade so viel,
ändert gibt's denn jetzt eigentlich einen festen startplatz eigentlich nicht ne da wird dann immer ausgewählt je nachdem wohin man.
Wir haben ja gut okay also wenn man wenn man nach osten will beziehungsweise halt in in inkarnation,
die bahn neigung zum equator sozusagen unterhalb von fünfundfünfzig grad,
dann ist die wahl wenn man darüber hinausgeht ist die wahl,
also die sozusagen die sogenannten polaren orbis da muss man von baden-württemberg aus staaten ist einfach damit zu tun dass halt wo land im weg ist sozusagen man versucht man versucht land zu vermeiden wenn man,
mit raketen pflegt,
vor allen dingen halt ja und jetzt mittlerweile sind wir relativ sicher von daher ist es nicht mehr ganz so kritisch aber das ist so die basis einrichtungen sagen wir wie sie wollen jetzt was weiß ich das sind ja satelliten,
starten dann dann ist eben die waren dann haben wir da eben zwei startplätze wir haben den hinein das ist der alte apollo startplatz das ist auch noch so ein ding nicht da sind
apollo und und fast alle shuttle flüge von von dort hinein abgegangen.
Und und das halt auch ein ziemlich ziemlich historisch belastender platz also im guten sinne in dem fall und dann gibt es noch das sie vor die was auf der südseite ist von generell und da starten wir halt die meisten kommerziellen davon,
und das ist ein bisschen ein bisschen kleiner da startete früher die große große gar nicht,
die große frage nein aber vielleicht ein bisschen größer tatsächlich aber.
Da starten halt thorsten als unsere kommerziellen von von da aus weil wir können im prinzip mischen auch wir können tatsächlich um einen startplatz auf einen anderen gehen wenn wir das früh genug wissen.
Sind die startplätze denn jetzt spacex explizit zugeordnet weil da gehört ja technik auch dazu ist ja nicht so dass man da irgendwo hinstellen kann und man startet mal von damals von dasein der ganze ort muss ja von der versorgung von der technischen anbindung her für diese rakete gebaut sein.
Denn wir bauen auch die die startplätze dann auf nicht als wir.
Bauen sozusagen die richtigen tanks da hin dann film hat ja mit den richtigen flüssigkeiten auch alles alles durchaus verschiedenen bei den raketen und dann haben wir halt eben entsprechend eine schnittstelle zu dem zu dem was wir,
diese diese dieses gerüst womit ihr rakete raustragen ist wenn wir die transporter director und der wird da eingeklinkt und dann entsprechend hochgehoben,
dafür brauchen wir auch entsprechend die ganze die ganze hardware am boden ne.
Basics die werden alle horizontal.
Die werden alle horizontal genau genau wir bauen ja okay der horizontal zusammen,
im im hänger sozusagen wie ein bisschen ein flugzeug nicht und dann kommen sie auf dieses gerüst drauf aber die sind den backbord sozusagen und dann rollen wir sie raus und stellen sie vertikal hin und starten sie dann.
Und das zusammenbauen das passiert halt in den wochen davor typischerweise haben wir,
benutzen wir wir machen ein ein sogenanntes fire wo wir die ganze rakete zusammenbauen aber keine pilot draufmachen fahren sie raus und feuern firma für vierzig drei und sieben sekunden,
wenn das halt ja dann passiert ist dann dann weiß ich auch okay jetzt ist der zeitplan relativ sicher ja weil das ganze die ganze rakete zusammen funktionierte.
Wir haben es einmal betankt einmal wieder leergelassen ausgelassen fahren sie wieder zurück dann kommt die piloten vorne drauf je nachdem was das ist ein dragon oder halt satellit ich glaube wir hatten gesagt wir machen satelliten als beispiel nicht.
Ist mir letztlich egal was es ist.
Und dann kommt er halt noch ein feeling drumrum ja und dann fängt so langsam an am so ein paar tage davor wenn wir halt bevor wir rausholen müssen die schiffe raus,
also zum beispiel das muss so drei vier tage vorher losfahren vielleicht auch fünf manchmal weil's halt weg ist das wird dann halt schon mal los.
Wie weit draußen ist das das ist ja schon ziemlich weiter.
Paar hundert ist ein paar hundert kilometer ja ich versuche auch immer zu vermeiden zu sagen wo die sind weil ich will wirklich nicht dass der leute irgendwie dann,
wenn man sich das angucken nicht dass es offensichtlich das wäre das wäre ziemliches desaster für uns ist ein paar hundert kilometer wie gesagt die die turnschuhe fährt halt was weiß ich vier tage vorweg,
um sich dann entsprechend zu platzieren bevor das passiert wahrscheinlich erst um die gleiche zeit fahren auch mittlerweile diese ferien schiffe berge das feeling auffangen wollen also das ist durchaus aufwand fahren die beiden schiffe raus,
wir sind da noch am testen wir machen so bestimmte letzte test wo wir halt die konfiguration sicherstellen die software ist genau richtig alles ist entsprechend konfiguriert,
und die die ganze sequenz die halt diese rakete durcharbeitet ist halt auch so wie sie sein muss.
Dann kommt die nutzlast obendrauf wird auch nochmal getestet wahrscheinlich je nachdem was es halt ist und dann rollen wir sie eben raus und am tag wo er dann starten,
da hat er auch entsprechende entsprechende aufwand mit wetter bind,
wir müssen die winde oben vor allen dingen halt a palette das sind so die winde die die rakete quer beeinflussen für ein flugzeug ist das ja sozusagen wo man mit schwimmt ja die sind entweder hätte oder oder teil wind,
durchaus
dramatisch der unterschied sein kann und für eine rakete das ist halt ein wind wo sie sozusagen quer durchschneidet und dann kommt der wind sozusagen von der seite und da muss man halt entsprechend gegensteuern und das kann also wenn man was falsch macht kann das paketen zerbrechen,
da muss man also sprechen messungen machen und und sicherstellen dass es alles okay ist und dann hat das auch wieder ein bisschen einfluss darauf wie man eben steuert.
So was passiert in den tagen halt davor dann am tag des staats,
wir gehen halt warnung an flugzeuge und schiffe dass sie sich aus diesem gebiet fernhalten müssen.
Ich habe immer sorgen das schiff schiffe flugzeuge sind ja relativ diszipliniert die die für die ist das ein problem wenn sie da bei erwischt werden dann kriegen die piloten die leisten die tänzen erzogen.
Die haben auch glaub ich gar kein interesse daran.
Genau die wollen das gar nicht machen ja ja das ist das ist das ist klar ja schiffe,
das ist ein bisschen anders normalerweise ist es ein bisschen bisschen lockerer und nicht ganz so kontrolliert nicht also wir haben öfter mal,
probleme gehabt wo wart überlegt haben ist das schiff was das schiff muss jetzt weg nicht ja das pferd da genau rein dieses gebiet und damit versucht den dieses schiff zu kontaktieren aber da hat es auch funktioniert oder auch in dem falle von kindern wenn das so schiffe am,
in der nähe der küste sind dann fliegt die die erfurtern helikopter raus und dann haben wir dann über den schiff.
Teilweise hat das funktioniert heißt teilweise hat es auch nicht funktioniert.
Genau wir hatten auch schon verspätung deswegen nicht aber da wird dann richtig so eine so eine flasche runtergeschmissen entsteht fahre hier weg,
war zum glück noch nicht empfangen seite aber ich habe da schon ab und zu mal so halt mitbekommen.
Was für ein hinweis vorsicht es könnte raketen regnen.
Genau naja ich meine im prinzip passiert dann halt auch nichts aber es hat eine sicherheit sache,
dann haben wir halt mittlerweile das ganze so entwickelt dass wir halt 'ne menge automation am boden auch haben und im prinzip drücken wir ein paar stunden vorm start den knopf,
und dann läuft er halt so eine maschine diese maschine sprichwörtlich ja das ist alles im programm und das programm schaltet halt am boden dieses ventil und jenes ventil an,
was weiß ich in diese druck tanks und ohne druck tanz
wir fangen tatsächlich sehr spät einzutanken nicht also wir fangen irgendwie fünfunddreißig minuten vorher an zu tanken,
fängt das kerosin anzuschließen sozusagen in die erste stufe die zweite stufe wird in der letzten viertel stunde geladen wird sozusagen der der flüssige sauerstoff da hochgebracht und,
innerhalb von drei minuten muss fertig ist fliegen wir.
Das später betanken ist damit man nicht so viel verluste hat.
Genau weil sonst wärmt der sauerstoff sich auf und fängt an zu kochen und das wollen wir nicht haben nicht gekühlte sauerstoff ist besser für uns der ist dichter und dann kriegt man mehr in ihrer kette rein,
das gleiche auch der fall für's kerosin wobei kerosin nicht ganz so schnell aufwärmt und das schon immer immer verblüffend wie spät wie spät,
tanken in dem sinne nicht das sieht man auch wenn man das bei diesen webcasts sieht dann fängt das leben an entsprechend zu zu kompensieren und zu zu dampfen sozusagen hinaus das würde es dampfen aber es tatsächlich feuchtigkeit.
Und das passiert halt in den letzten jahren was weiß ich zwanzig minuten im prinzip von der von der von der ganzen sequenz und dann dann starten wir halt bestätigen gerade nochmal mit der range dass alles okay ist sofort aber,
das programm läuft die ganze zeit durch ja und wir bestätigen nur noch dass wir sozusagen auch starten können ja dann startet halt ihre pakete die erste stufe zündet,
typischerweise zwei drei sekunden bevor man loslässt wir lassen die raketen die motoren ein bisschen laufen und dann ist das so ein aktiver aktiver release wo wir halt clemems gehen halt weg das kann man auch sehen,
und ja kritisch da steigt dann hoch.
Ich habe ich habe mir gerade nochmal den webcasts vom letzten start angeschaut und ich blicke immer fasziniert auf die art und weise wie der countdown angewendet wird weil es gibt ja diesen unterschied zwischen europäern und amerikanern dass die europäer bei null,
die raketen zünden.
Wir machen das wir wollen los bei null.
Genau und in amerika wird bei null abgehoben.
Ich bin noch nie bewusst gewesen wirklich ich glaube das nicht bewusst.
Ich weiß noch nicht ob space-x jetzt genauso hält aber für vermute mal ja.
Wir machen das immer bei bei null wollen wir los ja aber das ist auch das ist halt also wenn wir die die bahn berechnung da ist unsere null sozusagen und nicht irgendwie drei sekunden davor ja.
Naja also bei ariane ist es ist es sozusagen es ist null der zeitpunkt wo gezündet wird.
Weil.
Warum auch immer.
Okay also der der definitive zeitpunkt für uns die null ist es wenn man loslässt weil dann dann beginnt sozusagen auch der flug und die die muss man halt programmiert hat ja,
die motoren der erste stufe brennen ungefähr hundertfünfzig zweieinhalb minuten so in dem dreh,
das hängt auch ein bisschen davon ab wo wir hinfliegen also wenn wir zum beispiel eine township landung haben dann brennen sie ein bisschen länger wenn wir wieder zurück zum land nehmen dass man das nennen wir dann ritual tolerant
das am brennen sie vielleicht ein bisschen ein bisschen kürzer aber mehr sprit brauchen um wieder zurückzukommen da davon ab wie das missions profil ist aber wenn wir jetzt zum download fahren fliegen mal nicht
dann bremse halt was weiß ich zweieinhalb minuten dann geht die erste stufe halt eben aus wir warten ein bisschen dann trennen wir die zweite stufe ab
und dann ziehen wir den motor der zweiten stufe das ist auch ein handwerk also in berlin motor wie in der ersten stufe nur mit der kursraum düse gleich motor im prinzip.
Und dann geht er die zweite stufe auf den weg und die erste stufe fängt an ihrem manöver zu machen das heißt sie dreht sich so nicht ganz um hundertachtzig grad herum und,
geht dann die erste stufe fliegt sozusagen noch weiter hoch bis ihr halt auf auf ihren ist was ungefähr bei hundertzwanzig hundertdreißig kilometern ist.
Ja der höchste punkt genau und dann tritt sie halt nach ungefähr sechs sieben minuten tritt sie wieder einige atmosphäre am,
da gibt's auch.
Die stadt gehen ja immer gerne posten und das heißt wenn gelandet wird aufgrund.
Muss man wieder ganz zurück.
Dann muss man sozusagen wirklich wieder zum ursprungsort das ist ja eigentlich viel aufwendiger.
Genau genau.
Wird das nur gemacht wenn in wendenburg gestartet wird oder was.
Wird auch gemacht fürs geld wenn man die folgen heavy hat ja auch immer die land landung gemacht.
Ja aber wovon hängt das jetzt ab ob man im wasser landet oder wieder auf land.
Zeigt nur davon ab wie viel energie man braucht um den satelliten zu schmeißen wenn wir wenn wir mehr energie brauchen dann können wir keinen land landung machen wenn wir weniger brauchen kann man eine land landung machen.
Also wenn sozusagen genug reserven da sind dann lohnt es sich quasi ein land zurückzukehren weil dann muss man es ja auch nicht draußen auf dem wasser kostet ja auch alles geld und zeit und so weiter und kann schiefgehen landwirte sozusagen cooler aber wenn man das ganze die ganzen.
Fenster muss dann machen wir halt die tonchefin ja und die meisten die meisten die euch das satelliten haben relativ viel energie also die sind meistens alle an an an an john chips
und ja andere wie zum beispiel was was ich dragon hat manchmal genügend energie um zurück zu kommen zum land manchmal nicht hängt davon ab wie die mission halt wie schwer die mission ist,
ja genau also im prinzip wenn wenn man für land landung haben wir den sogenannten backburner wo dir die erste stufe sich dann nach der trennung umdreht und zwar so schnell umdreht dass,
die die drehung wird danach gestoppt mit dem triebwerk.
Ja wir haben wir haben so wir haben toaster vorne die die rakete umdrehen und die doch relativ stark aber wir beschleunigen die drehung so dass man dass man danach das triebwerk zünden muss um die drehung wieder aufzuhalten,
das hat schon sequenz und ziemlicher ziemlicher,
manöver das muss einfach klappen nicht dass der motor muss zünden und da muss ja entsprechend auch die die rakete wieder stabilisieren und dann für diese saison wieder zurückgeschossen zum land mit ungefähr zwanzig fünfundzwanzig sekunden fast,
und wenn man sich die die den den die bahn ansieht die kannst du sagen dann immer auch hoch und wieder zurück zum land.
Also sieht ein bisschen sieht ein bisschen komisch aus ja kann ich auch schwer beschreiben irgendwie da gibt's ein paar webseiten bestimmte,
grafiken hier ist halt entsprechend auch zeigen wie wie wir wieder zurück zum land fliegen das ist der sogenannte backburner und auch in diesem falle ist er wieder eintritt halt dann nach ungefähr sieben minuten so in dem dreh,
passiert dann halt um zu dem zeitpunkt.
Das heißt der unterschied zwischen will der prinzip jetzt erstmal konzentrieren wir uns jetzt quasi auf die landung also die rakete ist gestartet die erste stufe brennt wie lange ungefähr.
Ungefähr zweieinhalb minuten.
Zweieinhalb minuten da wird sozusagen erstmal die hauptarbeit geleistet da wird auch glaube ich in dieser max moment.
Sekunden im prinzip siebzig achtzig sekunden.
Das ist sozusagen die maximale luftwiderstand also man dadurch dass man immer noch in der luft ist die zwar immer dünner wird aber man immer schneller fliegt nimmt dieser luftwiderstand immer weiter zu.
Da kommt so eine kombination zum einsatz der halt schneller und dadurch hat der der druck halt immer höher und auf der anderen seite ist sind die atmosphäre wird auch nicht so schnell dünn dass das dass man schneller werden kann also das läuft dann sozusagen zusammen
und das ist typischerweise auch weiß eigentlich gar nicht warum das,
so eine bedeutung hat aber das ist halt wo es halt am meisten rappelt und und das fühlt sich so an als hätte man durch irgendein bestimmtes auszusagen durchgehen ja,
ist aber nicht ganz so im prinzip einfach nur ein bisschen bisschen gerappelt.
Die maximale last die sozusagen auf dem raketen körper liegt aber das wird alles noch von dieser ersten stufe geleistet.
Genau das wird alles das passiert alles in den ersten lassen zweieinhalb minuten.
So dann trennt sich erste stufe zweite stufe ab das wird ja ganz klassisch gemacht.
Ungefähr.
Verbindung.
Nee nee nee nee nee nee wir machen was ganz anderes nee nee wir also erstmal dass es so um die um die sechzig kilometer höhe jetzt ja wo die abtrennung ist ja und wir haben problematische verbindung,
ja wir haben also im prinzip kolben und und mechanismen die dann auseinander gehen und dann haben wir auch kolben die die die die erste stufe und die zweite stufe auseinander schieben,
mit relativ viel problematik im prinzip ist das und und,
ist was ganz anderes als als büro pyrotechnik weil man das halt eben auch entsprechend testen kann ich wir testen das am boden einmal durch ok geht alles klar wegen war.
Das heißt das ist etwas wo es die falko auch anders macht als die anderen raketen oder ist es mittlerweile auch bei anderen schon angekommen.
Naja ich glaube dass noch keine rakete nachfragen nein entwickelt worden außer vielleicht.
Ok ok also ist sozusagen ein alleinstellungsmerkmal an der stelle.
Ja genau ja habe ich ein gutes beispiel für früher gewesen ihr was anderes machen.
Ja das kann ich mir schon gut vorstellen dass das schon gar nicht mehr so klar ist aber das ist ja offensichtlich dann okay also ich würde quasi durch luft nach hinten weggeschubst da sind ja so diese ikonischen bilder die man immer kennt.
Genau genau.
Die eine stufe dann nach hinten taumelt und dann ist ja normalerweise da ist ja dann normalerweise ende dann tom.
Von der ersten stufe.
Dann taumelt die einfach die atmosphäre glück ein bisschen hin der rest fällt ins meer und dann haben wir wieder ein bisschen mehr schrott im meer.
In unserem fall fängst du auch eigentlich etwas fest an mittlerweile.
Genau und jetzt kommt sozusagen dieser dieser moment der landung sei einleitung und das beginnt dann erstmal dadurch dass ihre kette erstmal in eine richtung zeigen muss also in dem moment wo sie abgestoßen wird taumelt sie ja.
Dreht er sich um na ja.
Oder ist sie sofort unter kontrolle.
Die sofort eine kontrolle.
Okay und die kontrolle sagt ich muss mich jetzt umdrehen ich muss quasi mein mann mein arsch nach vorne bekommen um einfach.
Genau natürlich einmal um hundertachtzig grad rum bremsen genau.
Bremsen zu können weil dieses bremsen ist erforderlich um überhaupt erst wieder fallen zu können.
Nicht ganz also wie gesagt wenn ich zurück muss muss ich nicht bremsen sondern ich muss tatsächlich die geschwindigkeit umändern nach hinten ich geh in diese richtung ich will in dieser in die andere richtung da muss sich gegen gegen schub leisten ja das heißt ich muss.
Jetzt bremsen nennen würde.
Ja bremsen und meer ja rückwärtsgang will ich dazu fassaden.
Ok rückwärtsgang genau.
Also wir mussten rückwärtsgang aber der rückwärtsgang der der der macht mich nicht nicht langsamer in dem sinne bringt mich nur diese geschwindigkeit geht nur die andere richtung ja und ihrer kita wird da weiter sich auch höher,
also das sind da dass das fallen würdest du sowieso die erde anziehungskraft sie das macht aber die horizontale geschwindigkeit muss wieder zurück.
Und das dauert halt was weiß ich zwanzig fünfundzwanzig sekunden mit dem bus berg-ahorn typischerweise dass drei motoren die wir dafür brauchen weil die rakete ist jetzt fast leer,
was vorher halt den nutzlast war und die zweite stufe die auch relativ schwer ist dann jetzt hat man nur noch die lehre erste stufe und ein bisschen treibstoff den wir halt für jeden bus berg tribünen und landung brauchen.
Und da kommt nur noch drei motoren zum einsatz.
Da kommen drei motoren zum einsatz ja die drei motoren die erzeugen relativ hohe g-kräfte auf die rakete nicht also sind da durchaus irgendwie was weiß ich vier fünf sechs g,
wieder auf den auf die rakete wirken das sieht man nicht so richtig wenn man das irgendwie im video ist aber dass ein durchaus hohe kräfte,
ja boris becker und dann kommt die rakete halt wieder auf die bahn die halt zurückgeht und geht halt auch durch ein durch höchster punkt dann fängt sie so langsam an wieder zu fallen und dann werden bevor oder.
Wie track sich denn jetzt diese stufe weil die muss ja quasi auch ihre position und ihr ziel auch irgendwie kennen es halt nochmal ein star trecker drin oder was.
Die stufe hatten den gleichen gleiche navigation oder fast die gleiche navigation wie die zweite stufe auch gleiche kreisel im prinzip und die ps,
unten unten zu komputer im prinzip kann man gleich kommt zur computer die rakete ob das erste oder zweite stufe ist sind beide man muss den computern sagen du bist die erste stufe für stufe ja aber die sind beide im prinzip identisch.
Die rakete kann sich an der stelle per gps orten.
Kannst du immer.
Ich weiß nicht irgendwo auf einer bestimmten höhe dürfte das ja dann auch nicht mehr so ohne weiteres funktionieren oder.
Der das das das das das das ps im telefon hat eine bestimmte obergrenze aber da sind wir natürlich von ausgenommen.
Da braucht man da braucht man eine genehmigung vom vom department des fans glaube ich und dann ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau wie das heißt aber das tatsächlich auch was man.
Military great.
Nein nicht das hat damit nichts zu tun das ist einfach nur eine eine höhenverstellung militärisch geht ist noch was anderes ja aber guter punkt das sollte man vorher testen nicht das verändern.
Aber das heißt dass die stufe quasi von gps abhängig ist oder könnte sie auch.
Sie können doch ohne gps laufen ja.
Und woran orientierst du dich dann.
Nach wie vor den kranken kreisel nach wie vor nicht kein mechanisch kreise natürlich das sind das sind das freibad freibad optik weisel kreisel und und daran spricht beschleunigungs messer also.
Daraus ergibt sich ja noch keine position ist ja sozusagen nur die lage.
Doch das muss naja die betreuung,
nehmen halt so ein bisschen die die navigation auch wenn man die klage dabei weiß das ist im prinzip ein bisschen der tracking oder der blinde navigation nur mit einem mit einem mit einer beschleunigungs messung und einer lage lagermäßig.
Okay das heißt ihr rechnet quasi nach wo sie sein müsste.
Genau wenn ich damals gerade senkrecht war bevor ich gestartet bin und auf diesem startplatz war dann bin ich jetzt hier ja so und so läuft das im prinzip so ein bisschen langwierig aber.
Das wird überprüft werden ob diese berechnung auch tatsächlich mit dem was man per gps bekommt übereinstimmt.
Genau also tatsächlich wenn gps eben funktioniert dann würde ich sagen okay sagt hier dann nehme ich mal p s ja.
Und wie genau ist es so also wenn man so kreisel berechnungen und gps berechnung vergleich.
Die sind sehr sehr gleich ja gleich ich meine wenn man jetzt eine minute wartet eine minute ps verliert dann würde das langsam auseinandergehen ja,
aber bis bis also von sagen wir mal von einem zyklus zum anderen was weiß ich dass das wieder wieder rechner läuft hat.
Also mit was für eine abweichung muss man hier rechnen bei diesen geschwindigkeiten diesen höhen der remix von metern kilometern meter ok.
Tatsächlich ist das meer so eine sache von von von neuss oder einfach fehler in der messung sozusagen und weniger als einfach trifft in den in den system.
Okay die weiß wo sie ist.
Die akita weiß wo sie ist genau und dann sagt sie also okay also nach dem bus berg behörden der bus ist so gemacht dass die rakete sozusagen auch wieder da zurück kommen wo sie hingeht ja
die sagt sie sagt machte zum bus dass sie sagen wir mal einen kilometer vom landeplatz wieder landen würde,
mal einfach ein bisschen sicherer zu sein zählt man nicht ganz zum landeplatz sondern kilometer davor
und dann konflikte halt wieder nach oben kommt runter geht fähre langsam rein und ab einem bestimmten punkt sagst du okay ich werde jetzt nochmal ein bisschen bremsen ja das ist der sogenannte.
Der zweite band den wir machen und der burn ist.
Auf welcher höhe findet er statt.
Das ist eine gute frage ich glaube das sind irgendwie um die dreißig kilometer.
Also da ist die rakete schon wieder in ordentliche atmosphäre eingetaucht.
Na ja es ist kurz bevor eigentlich ja.
Kurz bevor so richtig.
Genau man man man wenn man sich so vorstellen kann man tritt so ein bisschen auf die bremse bevor es richtig heiß wird ja und der effekt ist dass es eben nicht ganz so heiß wird,
und das ist tatsächlich ziemlich ziemlich smartphone nichts da haben sie eine einige kluge leute bei uns aufkommen dass das eine methode ist wie man halt so ein bisschen so die die tribüne entry den wieder eintritt etwas was harmloser gestalten kann ja,
und auch ein bisschen flexibler dass sozusagen eine eine heiße mission hatte halt ein längeren tribüne und eine normale mission hat vielleicht auch manchmal gar kein ja.
Aber man kann ja jetzt nicht beliebig langsam werden weil man braucht schon eine gewisse geschwindigkeit auch damit diese rakete sich weiter stabilisiert oder.
Na so viel bremsen wir dann auch nicht wissen das bewegt sich durch.
Ja man könnte ja denken so da bremsen wir einfach mal total ab und fliegen wie so ein fallschirm nach unten das funktioniert wahrscheinlich nicht so.
Nee ich glaube wir bremsen weiß gar nicht genau sagen aber noch einige einige,
entweder macht zwei oder drei im dreh alles durchaus noch schnell verdammt schnell ja wenn man das in dem video sieht man das die haben diese diese diese fans ja die hinten in der rakete die geben uns nochmal die möglichkeit ihre kette besser zu steuern.
Die werden ja auch vorher vor diesem entry burn ausgeklappt.
Genau wir werden vorher ausgeklappt ja und dann hat man sieht man halt wenn die atmosphäre gehen wenn die an diese blaue ionisierte luft die sich da bildet und und manchmal sieht man noch ein paar funken davon wegfliegen ne also da ist durchaus ein haufen energie dahinter,
und,
zwischen mit dem andré burn-out und diesen diesen diesen sogenannten fenster wird dann halt in ihrer kita auch so gesteuert das jetzt ein bisschen näher am landeplatz ist vielleicht nur noch hundert meter weg oder so.
Also vom vom in der horizontalen.
Diese gitter flossen das war ja im prinzip so ein bisschen der,
der schlüssel dieses landen an sich hinzubekommen wenn wir vorhin schon drüber gesprochen erster ansatz war so fallschirm vielleicht funktioniert das hat alles überhaupt nicht funktioniert,
und dann ist ja diese ganze lande technik die wir jetzt beschreiben ist ja quasi dann mal komplett neu ausgedacht worden er hat gesagt ja ok was wäre wenn wir einfach kontrolliert zurückfliegen was brauchen wir denn dann auch in erodynamik hinsicht um überhaupt so eine rakete
wieder sicher landen zu können zu welchem zeitpunkt kam denn diese flossen dann überhaupt ins spiel.
Also die die die der hauptunterschied war sozusagen die sogenannte learning also für landen unter unter unter schub sozusagen machen ja,
die griffins selber hat man hätte auch anders machen können man hätte im prinzip sagen können wir nehmen normale fans und klappen die sozusagen zur seite oder so ja,
also wie das ist es im prinzip egal solange man da oben was hat womit man die rakete oben auch so ein bisschen steuern kann ohne dass das triebwerk läuft.
Und und,
das es gibt uns halt die möglichkeit wenn der schub sozusagen aufhört nach dem so zu steuern dass sie dass sie immer.
Projiziert sozusagen ganz nicht am landeplatz ist,
eigentlich wegläuft und also das die die die namibische steuerbarkeit die braucht man schon ob das jetzt eine grit findest oder irgendwas anderes naja gipfeln hat im prinzip ein paar vorteile,
ist einfach kompakter und und lässt sich gut ranklappen und und einfacher als eine als eine große flosse halt ne,
man hätte man jetzt auch anders machen können.
Okay also man hätte irgendwas nehmen können aber wichtig ist dass man überhaupt irgendwas hatten dass man's gut steuern kann sind ja auch ein paar mal verbessert worden ich glaube mittlerweile sind die aus titan damit sie irgendwie auch wiederverwendbar sind.
Zweite version ist halt aus titan sieht ein bisschen anders aus ein bisschen länger geworden und so sachen aber es ist halt auch ja genau wiederverwendbar.
So das heißt die rakete also die stufe die klappt jetzt sozusagen ihr röckchen aus drückt dann einmal aufs bremspedal also nach dem bus bergbahn um sich um zu orientieren gibt's den entry burn um erstmal geschwindigkeit rauszunehmen und um dann mit
weniger geschwindigkeit als es sonst gewesen wäre in die atmosphäre einzutauchen und ab dem moment sind aber eigentlich diese griffins dann beginnt zu dieser,
dieser tanz in der luft ne.
Sieht man auch sich bewegen und und und dann also ich kann daran sehen ob sie schwer arbeitet oder ob sie aus ziemlich auf kurs ist ja wenn da viel viel wackelig ist dann weiß er kämpft ein bisschen ja.
Wie viel ist davon im simulator entstanden und wieviel wurde dann erst im rahmen der mission wirklich perfektioniert.
Ist ja schon ein sehr komplexes problem.
Also was dabei ungenau ist also es ist im prinzip ja der einfluss von diesem
also wie die aerodynamisch halt sein wie gut die erde sind und der simulator als ministerin wir benutzen normalerweise hat damit relativ wenig zu tun ja da sind eine behalten,
competition ist ein andere programme und und wenn die halt gut waren dann war das im prinzip von vornherein so geplant ich muss sagen,
von vornherein ging das eigentlich relativ gut,
da war nie irgendwie was dabei wo wir gesagt haben oh das ist ganz anders als erwartet da waren so ein paar details wo wir dachten
komisch was sie hier macht ja ist aber alles irgendwas was wir erklären konnten dass was ich die pakete hat auf der außenhaut so sogenannte holt die kabel drin sind so sachen die haben tatsächlich den einfluss.
Aber so im groben und ganzen würde ich sagen das war schon.
Ziemlich genau was wir erwartet hatten dafür dass es halt auch eine flugkörper ist erhalt von macht zehn auf auf gar nichts geht ist auch schon durchaus bemerkenswert.
Ja auf jeden fall es gab doch diesen prototypen glaube ich mit dem diese ersten landung getestet worden wie heißt das ding grasshopper.
Grashopper genau und später war das dann mal so ein bisschen durch krass.
Die hüfte immer so ein bisschen durch das war ganz lustig aus aber da kam diese fenster noch gar nicht zum einsatz.
Die fans waren bei der grashopper nicht dabei krass aber ist noch ohne fans geflogen was auch geht ja ist ein bisschen schwieriger,
grasshopper hat vor allem die landet gemacht wie landet man die rakete und und behalten experimental programm ja weil auch da waren irgendwie zwanzig leute dran beteiligt das war schon durchaus spannend.
Weil er dann auch noch auch nochmal die die triebwerke dann auch nochmal zum einsatz kommen auf den letzten metern.
Genau wie wie man wie man halt ob man die man halt so ein triebwerk ansprechend steuert und zu landen das haben wir mit grashopper erfahren ja und dann hat man auch noch eine andere version die ist die hatte dann schon die die ausklappbares beine,
und die hatte auch glaube ich schon die god fans,
allerdings waren wir nie hoch genug um das um um die kultfilm wirkungsvoll zu testen vor dem ersten flug war auch nicht notwendig wir hatten immer genügend mission wo man das sozusagen selber testen konnte.
Und war ja erstmal nicht so wichtig wäre so schön wenn es geklappt hätte aber wobei das immer so lustig ist wenn jemand sowas sagt weil man weiß halt schon das ist schon so ein bisschen,
das ist schon eine coole nummer so wenn's wenn es gelingt,
ok zurück zu dem anflug also.
Bayern ist gelaufen die fans sind jetzt voll am arbeiten das sieht man ja sehr schön in diesem anflug videos wie die dann wirklich auf alles
irgendwie reagieren wobei diese reaktion ist quasi immer eine reaktion auf geänderte lage da wird ja nicht wirklich.
Genau der anstellwinkel wird geändert bin flugzeug.
Das heißt genau die rakete weiß einfach so sollte es sein und wenn ich so bin dann fliege ich aber nicht in die richtige stelle also man muss ja quasi ein extrem fernes ziel sehr genau ansteuern.
Genau.
Und das könnte wahrscheinlich auch nochmal mehr zwischen applaus bekommen habe ich so den eindruck weil,
wie weit ist denn die rakete entfernt also man ist ja doch schon sehr weit geflogen jetzt mal davon ausgehen man geht wieder ganz zurück lassen wir vielleicht das erstmal raus machen wir erstmal so die die landung auf dem boden,
du bist ja dann zweieinhalb minuten schon hatte ja schon diverse kilometer zurückgelegt.
Die ist ungefähr sechzig kilometer raus glaube ich es im zeitpunkt ja.
In die höhe.
Und auch weiter.
Bis sie sich umdrehen.
Genau wie geht relativ steil hoch und gibt dann erst nach und nach in die horizontale bin ich ja so richtig im kopf habe ist nicht sehr viel weit was tatsächlich weit ist ist wo sie landen würde.
Das ist da wo das dongshik steht die rakete physikalisch ist gerade am anfang von der bahn aber die würde dann dahinten landen ja
also wenn man die schnell umdreht dann kann man sozusagen das noch korrigieren die na gut das sind sechzig kilometer ist oder sagen wir mal sechzig siebzig kilometer das ist immer noch immer noch ein haufen um jetzt halt eine punktlandung zu machen
und aber bei dem bus backburner muss man nicht so genau sein ja dann kann man ja durchaus innerhalb von,
sagen wir hundert meter das anpeilen ja und dann beim tribüne da will man das schon so vielleicht zehn meter möglicherweise anpeilen ja,
beim landungsbrücken da wird es halt eben entsprechend auf ein meter.
So läuft das im prinzip dass man von von der weite aus erstmal so ein bisschen grob anpeilt ja und dann wird das eben verfeinert als wie man näherkommt im prinzip nicht anders als man fliegt.
Okay aber trotzdem schon muss man schon einiges richtig machen mit dem kleinen röckchen ordentlich in die richtige richtung wedeln.
So genau dann kommt die eigentliche landung greifen also kommt dann auch kameras ins spiel oder bleibt es tatsächlich bei dieser positionierung wo bin ich.
In dem fall brauchen wir.
Für die landung.
Also die person und da ist nur ein radar drunter was ihr sozusagen die höhe sagt ja das war der flugzeuge haben das auch nicht aber nur da wo es halt was unterhalb fünfhundert meter sagt wie hoch das flugzeug ist bei der landung.
Was eine sehr gute hilfe piloten und im prinzip hat die die rakete die gleiche hilfe und was was mich bei der landung immer fasziniert ist der schub von einem das ist dann ein triebwerk typischerweise ja,
der schub ist so hoch dass ihre kita wenn sie nicht landen würde und in dessen den motor ausschalten will wird es wieder hochgehen
ein bisschen wie ein ballon landen ja und und das muss also genau im richtigen moment ausgeschaltet werden gelandet werden und und und an weil ansonsten geht das ding wieder hoch wenn wir sozusagen wenn wir
geschwindigkeit null in in zehn meter hätten dann müsst ihr nicht was er machen soll.
Genau im sinne von zehntel sekunden millisekunden wieviel toleranz ist da noch.
Ich glaube schon zehn titel und ein bisschen weniger vielleicht noch also es muss schon alles genau zusammenkommen am ende um um die rakete dann da zu landen wo sie auch landen muss ja,
und.
Und das ihr auch stehen bleibt.
Genau und das ist halt entsprechend auch ein haufen haufen arbeit gewesen vom algorithmus her dass das alles so zu miteinander zu verbinden ja,
typischerweise landete innerhalb von drei vier metern sozusagen das ist unser unser unsere genauigkeit,
größtenteils von von gps eben auch vorgegeben sondern es hat eben auch wind
es gibt so ein paar videos wo wo wir halt einen starken seitenwind landen und dann sieht man die rakete sozusagen in die in den winzig lehnen sondern in letzter sekunde suchst dann gerade stellt und und und auch auf dem auf dem lande
herta nacheinander lande zu nennen.
Das heißt auch so böen im letzten moment sind in gewisser hinsicht noch da kann man nur gerade noch so mit umgehen.
Böden sind glaube ich nicht so ein problem weil es einfach ist auch ein schwerer schwere schwere sache im prinzip nicht so schnell wie das nicht weggeblasen aber so schier winde also wo hat der wenn der wind am boden anders ist grundsätzlich ja das kann durchaus einen einfluss haben.
Aber das würde ja auch den staat unter umständen schon verzögern wenn solche bedingungen sind oder.
Staatsanwalt also wir haben durchaus staats gehabt mit zwanzig mal fünfundzwanzig malen stunde wind schon durchaus ein bisschen bisschen kräftiger und ist halt auch am,
am strand und da ist halt auch entsprechend erwähnt also von daher das schon durchaus wenn die geilen.
Okay das nennt man noch mit diese.
Drone chips also die ja jetzt sozusagen diese wasser,
plattformen die dann zum einsatz kommen wenn eben eine rückkehr nicht möglich ist wird gerade gelernt haben weil nicht genug sprit da ist die werden dann sozusagen dahin gefahren wo man ja gerade noch hinkommt,
weil der spritverbrauch dann deutlich geringer ist oder.
Weil wir haben halt.
Sicher das umdrehen das ist ja.
Genau das macht das macht eine menge aus ja ja also im vergleich dazu oder oder andersrum gesagt es gibt wesentlich mehr nutzlast in orbit,
dafür und das macht schon das ist die sache schon wert also ein schiff rausfahren kostet auch geld nicht das schiff selber kostgeld,
ja wir nennen das.
Ja und trotzdem lohnt es sich sozusagen dahinzufliegen.
Oh ja auf jeden fall ihrer kette kurz am meisten geld.
Kann man das so einfach umrechnen wieviel wieviel pilot man quasi gewinnt dafür dass man eben nicht zurück fliegt sondern auf diesem grundstück landet.
Kann man ich habe die ja kam kann man kann man glaube ich ich glaube nicht dass ich ich glaube die zahl der bin ich im kopf.
Aber dass du kilogramm oder.
Ton.
Schon tonnen okay also es macht richtig was aus sozusagen.
Wo irgendwo zwischen kilo zehn kilogramm eine tonne würde ich mal sagen.
Okay das lassen wir das offen von diesen gibt es mehrere glaube ich zwei oder drei.
Die eine einzige instructor das war bisher an der westküste glaube ich mittlerweile auch an der ostküste sind beide momentan an der ostküste das andere war auf kurs.
Das sind kulturelle grenzen auf ein.
Ihren banks heißt ja glaube ich ein science-fiction autor und in diesem buch,
titel weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht mehr aber in dem buch nennen sind die die raumschiffe klug genug sich selber den namen zu geben,
und das sind zwei zweite der schiffe die heißt halt entsprechend so instructor und auf kurs dollar.
Alles klar ok viel humor am start.
Genau.
Glaube ich auch noch diverse andere referenzen ne.
Na gut es gibt dann auch die beiden die beiden schiffe für die für die ferien von ursprünglich mister steven steven umbenannt worden in mistery mastery.
Misterium und unglück.
Und soweit soweit soweit ich weiß das comic figuren auch.
Okay wer ist für die benennung zuständig ist das.
Im endeffekt ich weiß nicht ob das also ich glaube der ihren banks seine idee bin ich sicher ob die misst misst misst misst schief auf auf seinem sein iran oder nicht also ich meine wir haben
leute die e-mail schicken wenn sie eine gute idee haben.
Ja also kultur referenzen an das ist ja jetzt in der raumfahrt auch nichts neues aber trotzdem schön.
Ja bisschen humor haben ist auf jeden fall kein fehler das zahlt sich am ende aus ich finde auch gerade die europäischen mission sind doch manchmal etwas trist benannt da geht noch was.
Ja
Ok jetzt haben wir im prinzip so 'ne.
Landung glaube ich ausreichend beschrieben vielleicht noch eine frage zu diesem drohen schiffen weil,
die führen ja auch nochmal eine gewisse komplexität hinzu ich weiß nicht ob die landesfläche die dort zur verfügung steht vergleichbar ist mit der die man hat nicht immer ansatz.
Kleiner ja kleiner.
Es hat ja am anfang nicht funktioniert.
Es gab.
Die die die allerersten landung waren auch auf dem ersten war auf dem schiff.
Genau auf dem schiff erstmal tatsächlich alle auf dem schiff und.
Auch aus sicherheitsgründen wahrscheinlich.
Genau genau und teilweise sind ja teilweise da dann eben die trümmer auf dem schiff geblieben und die haben zurückgefahren und es steht wieder zusammengebaut
da waren durchaus auch manchmal schweißarbeiten natürlich notwendig um die um die lande fläche wieder zu zu zu reparieren,
dann ich war gar nicht mehr genau wenn man relativ wir waren relativ dicht dran und dann hatten wir die erste land landung mit dem upgrade von falken nein,
gleichzeitig es sieht glaube ich voll der cup create.
Und das war tatsächlich sagen drei tage vor weihnachten zweitausendfünfzehn oder so und,
das war so für mich so ein bisschen so eine so eine nach mystery mission weil weil wir hatten lange zeit eine pause gehabt hätten probleme in der kita davor gehabt wir haben den fehler gefunden behoben upgrade gemacht,
und es war die erste land landung ja und und das hat einen haufen aufmerksamkeit auch eben bekommen wir hatten im team da was uns interviewt hatte,
kameras von überall und das war halt auch drei tage vor weihnachten und jeder war so ein bisschen ich will hier raus und und dann und dann,
funktionierte das tatsächlich und alles funktionierte der staat funktioniert wunderbar die rakete kam zurück und landete auf dem land und das war absolut phänomenal,
also da gibt's auch heute noch ein noch ein youtube-video von das ist absolut phänomenal.
Das habe ich mir mehrfach angeschaut das war auch das was ich vorhin meinte mit dieser überbordenden begeisterung.
Ja das war so dramatisch wie es tatsächlich da auch in dem video war also das video ist wenn ich mich täusche das war glaube ich sehr schnell team und die haben einfach einen fantastischen job gemacht damit diesen ganzen dokumentation.
Und das ist auch was was wie gesagt wir werden da gefragt ob sie es machen können und das ist nicht so irgendwas was wo wir versuchen irgendwie unser besseren nicht darzustellen das ist einfach so ist es.
Hallo.
Wo waren sie denn da waren sie da.
Ich war im kontroll raum.
Ja ich sage es tatsächlich neben milon und wir hatten tatsächlich in letzter minute noch probleme haben wir überlegt haben was was da irgendwelche parameter wo bedeuten und hatten dann entschieden das ist ok und das war auch die richtige entscheidung war war super spannend,
nach dem start ist heraus gerannt um die landung zu sehen und ich war halt wieder da geblieben und zu gucken was die was die zweite stufe noch macht weil das läuft ja alles immer gleichzeitig nicht wenn die erste stufe landet innerhalb von,
dreißig sekunden eine minute ist der der der schluss von der zweiten stufe burn ja,
und für mich die landung es war wichtig aber für mich ist eigentlich auch wichtig ich verstehen dass die dass die haut mission weitergeht dass die auch im richtigen brandschutz hat und im richtigen orbit ist,
wenn das nicht der fall ist dann muss man bodenstation umstellen und so weiter und so fort deswegen passt sich eigentlich auf die zweite stufe auf.
Das heißt ein bisschen schwierig sich so richtig zu freuen in dem moment.
Pass auf die zweite stufe auf.
Das heißt alle waren am jubeln und sich dann da immer noch so.
Der kontrolle raum ist normalerweise fokussiert auf die zweite stufe auch ja also es war ein bisschen ein bisschen erleichterung wenn das ding landet aber tatsächlich die die meisten.
Beim ersten mal.
Gute frage weiß ich nicht mehr ehrlich gesagt ich glaube schon also ich glaube schon dass da auch durchaus eine erleichterung war und es war klasse aber im prinzip mit einem auge guckt man immer auf die zweite stufe.
Das kann er sozusagen alles später.
Mittlerweile haben wir oft genug gemacht ich bin eigentlich ich bin immer noch im kontrolle raum wenn ich kann aber nicht mehr ganz so häufig wie damals damals war ich im prinzip bei jedem flug dabei.
Ja also jetzt verliert es natürlich so ein bisschen dass das neue wo es allerdings noch mal.
Richtig nochmal durch geatmet hat fand ich war der staat der falkon heavy.
Herr.
Einerseits weil das ja auch relativ problemlos funktioniert hat oder was ist da überhaupt irgendwas schief gegangen bin das war alles super.
Du wirst bemerkenswert auch.
Aber irgendwie war die landung von zwei raketen stufen parallel ja dann glaube ich auch nur im abstand von einer sekunde oder so auf.
Genau.
Das war dann irgendwie auch gleich nochmal nochmal so ein sahnehäubchen obendrauf auf diesem ganzen projekt weil es irgendwie was was kann ich was mir durch den kopf gegangen ist an dieser tanz der maschinen.
Das sieht bizarr aus ich weiß aber aber im prinzip ist das ganz banal das ist das gleiche programm auf beiden raketen die einige nach rechts nach links der andere hat den hat den rechten ja den link startplatz version.
Wenn invasion aus dem altern so.
Aber ich weiß dass sie sehr faszinierend aus aber es ist tatsächlich da ist nichts irgendwie die kennen sich nicht die beiden.
Das ist die zurückhaltung der ingenieure das mag ich das heißt die falcons heavy war am ende auch gar nicht so ein großes ding.
Na doch da schon ist halt schon noch ein haufen arbeit reingegangen zum einen halt die ganzen vitamix wenn man halt so drei raketen zusammen bindet ist es ganz anders ne,
da werden enorme kräfte zwischen diesen diesen gelenken halt hin und her geleitet oder kupplung oder was immer das ist ja und die ganze dynamik wie ich das auseinander trennt ist halt auch wesentlich komplexer
das ist schon alles schon alles ein haufen mehr aufwand gewesen und dann halt auch einfach drei erste stufen zu zu integrieren und testen ist einfach drama so viel arbeit und,
von daher ferkeln heavy ist für für für die ingenieure für uns eigentlich immer ja ein haufen arbeit.
Für ein ein großer größeren satelliten.
War es gab ja nur drei staats- her.
Drei staaten genau ein ein ein tesla s neun jahre von daher ein tesla
auch durchaus mit damen ja und und und ein eine mission der airforce die sehr schwierig war sehr komplizierter orbit und dann eben ein ein sehr schwerer nachrichten satellit.
Und wir haben einige missionen einige fragen harry mission momentan noch im manifest typischer was sind das schwere nutzlasten oder halt nutzlasten die ein bisschen weiter weg wollen.
Aber im kern ist sozusagen eine hervorragende wiederverwendung der technologie weil es ja im prinzip wirklich genau das ist was drauf steht nämlich ja ist eine falken aber ist halt heavy.
Ja ich meine vor allen dingen der vorteil ist halt das sind halt die ersten die die höhere aufwand liegt in der ersten stufe und die erste stufe ist das was wieder bekommen ja
und wenn wir irgendwas haben momentan sind als erste stufen
fliegen haufenweise auf startplatz rum momentan oder ein hang dazu vom wetter geschützt sind und und von daher die für verfolgen heavy benutzen macht sinn.
Ist halt auch entsprechend,
musst du mal sagen also in der wiederverwendbar zeit das war durchaus im prinzip eine sache die.
Sich wirklich fantastisch bewährt hat also,
wir haben jetzt den fall dass wir halt so viele stufen haben die wir weiter fliegen können wir haben jetzt die der letzte start war der vierte staat einer stufe,
die stufe wird nochmal fliegen und so weiter und so fort ja also wir werden.
Zehnmal soll das.
Ja zehn staatswohl kommen dann werden wir mal sehen wie das dann danach eben entsprechend aussieht ja und,
das hat die tatsache ist einfach statt zehn raketen brauchen wir nur eine das macht nach dem riesen unterschied ja gut man muss ja ein spazieren und ein paar sachen wissen wir jetzt damals ein bisschen genauer gucken aber eine lernkurve dabei ja aber
der der fakt ist einfach statt zehn raketen einzubauen ja das ist einfach ein riesiger unterschied.
Diese berechnungen was sind eigentlich die raumfahrt günstiger macht da gibt's ja im prinzip zwei vektoren dann gibt es auf der einen seite okay wieder verwendbarkeit aber auf der anderen seite auch massenproduktion,
was sozusagen ja so die theorie ist mit na wenn wir sozusagen immer wieder dasselbe bauen ein baum es halt so oft und dann ist das bauen selber günstiger,
jetzt irgendwie alles wiederverwendet baut man ja auf einmal nicht mehr so viel da hat man diese diese faktoren nicht mehr wie geht das so zusammen.
Ja so also mit der massenproduktion ich glaube massenproduktion ist tatsächlich billig wenn man was bei sich zehntausend mal sachen baut,
da stimme ich völlig zu recht aber so paketen werden hundert mal gebaut ich glaube nicht dass es einen großen unterschied macht also da geht die produktionskosten gehen wo schon ein stück runter ja,
aber eins zu zehn ist das nicht der der der faktor ist definitiv bei der wiederverwendbar keit größer,
würde ich mal so behaupten ja bis das bis mich jemand da sozusagen falsch prüft er,
der andere effekt von der wiederwahl verwendbarkeit ist noch dass man man kriegt ihr rakete zurück und kann also sehen wo was vielleicht geleckt hat oder so ja,
oder wo was schief ging oder was weiß ich was was wackelt jetzt ja und und das ist ja aber auch ein unglaublich großer faktor finde ich weil beim nächsten mal kann man sozusagen darauf achten dass diese verbindung entsprechend dicht ist ja,
und weiß jetzt so ein bisschen wie die sachen im flug passieren und wenn wir zum beispiel feststellen ok hier passiert irgendwas komisches dann packen wir in die kamera rein,
gucken am ende die kamera also eine kopie oder sowas ein in dreher.
Wirklich jetzt.
Ja und gucken uns am ende an was da eben aufgenommen wurde und stellen fest also um die zeit herum ist dann lecker.
Die kameras fliegen denn so mitte derzeit anders geht das schon einige ne.
Ich weiß das nicht mehr alles also ich weiß dass wir tatsächlich kriegen wahrscheinlich zehn runter oder so,
über über verbindung radio aber dann sind da nochmal oftmals was weiß ich ein paar handvoll kameras die doch nicht immer da bleiben die werden dann halt nur für diese mission da eingesetzt ja und wenn wir wissen was da wieder raus.
Ok
Also es ist nicht so nicht so dass das nur eine kamera haufen ist der da fliegt ja aber er hat schon so ein bisschen was.
Aber so für die booking ist das natürlich super wenn man sich das genau anschauen.
Was geht ab zweiten stufe nicht also man kann schon machen man kriegt die bloß nicht wieder das ist das macht einen riesen unterschied aber dadurch dass die erste stufe und die zweite stufe auch sehr gleich sind können wir alles auch sachen aus der ersten stufe lernen die wir dann in der zweiten stufe anwenden,
grundsätzlich würde ich mal sagen das macht die rakete besser nie wieder verwendbarkeit ja und am anfang war das halt auch so ein bisschen so leute waren ja,
ich möchte keine benutzte rakete und dann haben wir es immer entsprechend flight puppen genannt ja und dann.
Hallo.
Da passiert es auch schon.
Benutzt dies bewährt.
Genau genau da passiert aber auch so ein bisschen was in den leuten halt mittlerweile die meisten kunden finden das eigentlich nicht schlecht wenn die zweite mal fliegt,
beim ersten mal hat die sozusagen gezeigt dass er das kann alles okay es liegt ein zweites mal alles klar ja ich meine ich bin pilot wenn ich flugzeug aus dem aus der werkstatt kriege das ist so ein bisschen wenn ich so,
eine runde fliege und müssen vorsichtiger werden ja.
Könnte funktioniert haben vielleicht aber auch nicht.
Genau aber wenn ich dann danach noch aufkriege kein problem ja weil ich das wieder.
Ein ein ein guter aspekt dass dass man ja dadurch jetzt sozusagen ganz andere einblicke genießt wo früher einfach alles verglüht ist man froh war wenn's nicht explodiert ist kann man jetzt im detail verbesserungen vornehmen.
Und wenn man sich das genau überlegt die
die luftfahrt wurde eigentlich auch erst besser als man sozusagen den diese feedback hatte von den triebwerken kontinuierlich in die in die firmen die halt entwickelt haben und die jetzt unsere feststellen konnten wenn diese vibration auftritt dann
drei wochen später geht das ding kaputt ja und sozusagen die anzeichen jetzt erkennen können was da eben das problem ist und was halt eben auch entsprechend ein instrumentieren wichtig ist um das triebwerk,
zu überwachen und sicherzustellen dass es eben so lange fliegt nicht und deswegen kann man also heutzutage mit zwei motoren über den atlantik fliegen kein problem.
Zumindest kein problem an bis dann irgendwann mal irgendwelche messungen auftreten ja.
Dass ich hoffe dass das gleiche eintritt bei raketen im prinzip das war also eine unmenge an daten hat gewinnt und die entsprechend benutzt um die rakete sicherer zu machen zu dem punkt wo also dann eben auch entsprechend bemannte raumfahrt ja,
einfach und und unproblematisch wird wie die ja wenn man die luftfahrt.
Ist denn auch daran zu denken dass die zweite stufe in irgendeiner form nochmal wieder verwertet werden kann oder ist sie einfach zu weit weg.
Ja die zweite stufe hat ein bisschen zu viel energie und um die zweite stufe durchzubringen braucht man ein hitzeschild und das ist ein bisschen komplizierter.
Also zu viel energie die ist so sehr beschleunigt worden dass wenn man die abbremsen wollen würde.
Genau dann braucht man einfach ein großes hitzeschild dafür,
und das ist halt schon ein bisschen schwieriger schwieriger ist nicht dass wir es nicht probiert haben also wir haben durchaus,
versucht zu zu experimentieren mit mit mit der zweiten stufe nach dem nach der mission natürlich aber das ist eine sache die ist einfach ein bisschen zu
schwierig zumindest für falken nein stars shit das ist so ein bisschen das ist jetzt die neue entwicklung die wir halt haben star löst das problem in dem es von indem es also eine zweite stufe baut die von vornherein,
in den wiedereinzug dritt wieder eintritt machen kann.
Es sind das nur eine stufe also es es ist so.
Zwei stufen beim triebwerk antrieb werk.
Nee bei der falko ist es nur ist die zweite stufe ist ein triebwerk okay das heißt es macht auch nicht so viel aus ist quasi nur ein zehntel.
Von den kosten ja die zweite stufe ist nicht ein zehntel der kosten die ist ein bisschen mehr schauen weil da eben auch ein bisschen die das ein haufen nix drauf.
Typischerweise fickt es das bein auf der zweiten stufe mit also ist schon durchaus mehr als als zehn prozent.
Ok vom triebwerk ist ist identisch aber es sozusagen noch mehr als nur das triebwerk.
Das triebwerk ist auch ein bisschen,
das mehr redundanz an dem triebwerk dass alles doppelt ron und das hängt damit zusammen dass es nur ein triebwerk ist wohingegen die die möhren triebwerke der ersten stufe wenn da einmal eins ausfallen würde noch an bord dann,
dann würden wir nur ein triebwerk vermissen das wäre nicht so ein großes problem.
Jetzt ist ja auch schon mal passiert.
Ganz früh schlug vier oder so hatte einen triebwerke sind bei dem haben wir die die technologie von der brennkammer geändert,
wie man das baut und nimmst du nicht mehr passiert.
Was sind denn so andere verbesserungen die sich so in der falk nein dann durch diese regeneration durch dieses wiederverwenden und durch dieses begutachten des ergebnisses ergeben hat was,
dass du rein strukturelle minimal verbindung oder hat man irgendwie auch mal größere änderung herbeigeführt.
Ja ich meine ein fall zum beispiel ist diese diese dass wir unsere unsere treibstoff jetzt etwas kühler halten ja und und
man sozusagen auch verdichtet mit niedriger temperatur das ist eine eine verbesserung gewesen die ziemlich ziemlich dramatischen einfluss hatte,
darüber hinaus nicht oftmals nur kleinigkeiten wie was weiß ich die lande beine brauchen so viel dämpfer davon braucht man nur zwanzig prozent also nehmen einen kleineren dämpfer und so sachen ja.
Oftmals,
aufpassen dass so so in dem sinne kleinigkeiten oder wir stellen fest oftmals haben wir hier einen leckeren ändern wir die den den joint die verbindung halt entsprechend um um dann eben kein lack mehr zu haben ja,
und und so ist es halt nichts durchaus eine handvoll hier in da nicht,
oftmals noch viele verbände verbesserungen am boden ja wie man halt die rakete tankt und jemand hat sicherstellt dass das ist ja nun ein system das hat.
Bestimmte,
jetzt gibt's warnungen alerts und so weiter und all diese sachen während werden verbessert von staat zu staat er ist ein haufen einen haufen entwicklung reingegangen ist.
Jetzt haben wir es ja schon angedeutet mit volker nein ist das ende der fahnenstange noch lange nicht erreicht weil letzten endes will der elon will ja auf auf den mars wäre eigentlich immer noch selber hin.
Ich glaube ja.
Meine herren okay meinetwegen ich kann das nur begrenzt nachvollziehen aber man steckt ja nicht drin.
Das bedeutet man braucht im prinzip ja eine maschine die nochmal sehr viel mehr reisen kann während der falkon heavy zwar sehr viel stärker ist als die normale falko neun
als es ja auch nur schwere lasten aber alles noch
um die ader herum um es wirklich die anziehungskraft der erde zu verlassen die entsprechende fluggeschwindigkeit zu erreichen und um dann auch genug power zu haben,
um den master erreichen ist eine ganze menge mehr bums erforderlich und das ist ja jetzt das projekt stars ship,
beziehungsweise super heavy also das sind die beiden komponenten,
happy ist quasi die untere stufe wenn ich das richtig sehe und stars wie ist das was oben dran genagelt ist was dann halt letzten endes inter planeta unterwegs,
sein soll,
da wurde ja gab es viele überraschungen dass als jetzt dieser erste prototyp vorgestellt wurde dass er dann aus einem material gebaut war was glaube ich viele nicht so richtig auf der kette hatten normalerweise ist ja immer
aluminium am start aber hier kam dann einfach eine edelstahl hülle,
einsatz was ja schon mal den vorteil hat dass das ding wirklich extrem schick aussah.
Sieht schick aus nicht lass dich nicht.
Also so richtig zusammengeklöppelt so richtig so ein bisschen so fast schon so diese klassische drei pakete die man sich so im hinterhof eigentlich für die person persönlichen einsatz immer gewünscht hat,
hat aber ein grund weil hier glaube ich thermische fragen große rolle.
Ja gut es gibt zwei zwei zum einen beide treibstoffe darstellt benutzt mit methan und und flüssig sauerstoff also flüssiges methan flüssigen sauerstoff und der der vorteil von,
von stehen also das ist eine bestimmte metall serie ist halt dass es sehr sehr,
sehr kräftiges wenn's kalt wird also die temperatur hat einen positiven effekt auf den auf den ja auf dem material.
Und der zweite effekt ist dass das material auch relativ hohe temperaturen ab kann dann wieder eintritt ja also diese diese beiden effekte zusammen.
Aluminium ist gut auch wenn's kalt wird keine frage aber aluminium darf nicht besonders warm werden,
oder heiß werden ja und da ist halt halt dann stahl einfach günstiger zumal es gab auch schon andere raketen aus stahl atlas hat in der oberstufe,
alles selber glaube ich ich glaube die erste stufe auch aus dem stahl also von daher das ist durchaus nicht so so abwegig wie es aussieht der staat ist halt entsprechend dann auch dünn und muss halt ein pärchen auch mit druck stabilisiert werden.
Aber das ist ja auch generell so also ich glaube raketen halten sich immer auch dadurch dass sie befüllt sind.
Genau das ist im prinzip genauso bei allem genau genau die am ende der struktur die sie sozusagen unterstützen wie wie unser transporter der sich halt rausspringt oder die sind halt unter druck.
Und was ist jetzt hier das das ziel mit dem stars ship also was ist das aktuelle modell ist im prinzip ein reiner test prototyp oder.
Momentan noch ja aber hat ja.
Für mars das ist die das ist das ziel um damit zu maß gekommen ist noch erkennen sie hat neun meter durchmesser hat,
also schon schon eine ganze ecke größer ist die zweite stufe ist um die achtundsechzig meter glaube ich,
und die ersten hundert meter hoch ja also schon durchaus eine gigantische rakete da muss man auch entsprechend sehen wir bauen die sozusagen mit der portokasse.
Das ist nicht ganz nicht ganz wahr aber zum.
So eine bilo wegwerfen.
Na ja gut da muss man halt schon schon irgendjemand ein bisschen,
gucken was man so findet es ist kein großes programm das ist kein kein kein jetzt so wie ein government programm für für was weiß ich oder so wo der milliarden rheinwiesen ist so viel geld haben wir einfach nicht sondern dass halt durchaus auch,
creepy ist das englische wort dafür ich weiß gar nicht was das deutsche wort dafür ist.
Also hin gerotzt halt.
Da meinte ich ein anderes wort.
Okay so ein bisschen günstiger gebaut.
Kostengünstig bewährte materialien.
Genau bewährte materialien.
Und und ja genau wir haben jetzt also ein ein.
Zum mars fliegen ohne jetzt groß science dabei zu haben ist das überhaupt eine option also.
Also ich bin sicher da wird dabei sein ich meine wir haben jetzt auch erst mal bestellen sozusagen die morde mittel da zur verfügung und wie das am ende genau aussieht das werden wir noch sehen aber der der der,
der hauptpunkt ist momentan erstmal tatsachen zu schaffen dass man entsprechenden träger hat er das machen kann,
ja aber das ist der erste schritt dass so ein bisschen auf den falken eins ja wir müssen den ersten schritt machen dann bin ich sicher da wäre noch wann auf änderungen vorgenommen hier und da,
wir werden jetzt planen die kids zu entwickeln am hier dass sie erstmal eine arbeit geht hier und dann sehen wir wie das weitergeht mit mit zum maß war das haupt das hauptding ist eigentlich auf dem weg zum maß muss man die zweite stufe wieder volltanken im orbit.
Dass man sozusagen stars schiff ist dann ist zwar gestartet und ist dann in dem moment hat keinen treibstoff mehr dann werden halt mehrere hintereinander gestartet und füllen den den ursprünglichen staatschef wieder auf.
Und dann geht's eigentlich erstmal.
Und das tatsächlich ganz martin eine möglichkeit zum zum maß zu kommen ohne ohne jetzt die die die struktur.
So komplex zu machen vor allen dingen wenn man sich dabei überlegt dass die rakete wiederverwendbar ist,
dass man sozusagen diese diese betankung mission wieder zurück kriegt,
und eigentlich nur dafür den treibstoff bezahlen muss dann ist das eigentlich ein ding das kann tatsächlich funktionieren.
Das wäre ja.
Ich höre ich höre da schon so ein bisschen skeptisch ist hier nicht.
Nein ich meine da würde man ja wohl mal davon ausgehen dass das das ziel ist.
Ist es auch ich meine es ist tatsächlich eine architektur die halt,
darauf ausgelegt ist dass es dass es auch entsprechend bin niedrigen kostenlos trainieren man könnte auch andersrum maß kommen denke ich mir da gibt's auch eine methode
heavy könnte wohl auch mit einer dritten oberstufe mit der zweiten oberstufe
der dritte stufe zu maß kommen aber das wäre halt eben auch nur so ein bisschen einmal zweimal ja das ist immer von geldern abhängig wohingegen stars ship ist dann im prinzip auch die günstigste methode,
was zu machen.
Das heißt es ist eine komplette eigen- finanzierung von spacex und das ziel ist erstmal nur es getan zu haben oder.
Nein das jedes mal zu kommen.
Aber da fliegen ja jetzt sozusagen erstmal also mit mit personal.
Mit personal genau.
Beim ersten mal.
Mit benannt.
Das glaube ich eigentlich nicht ich glaube wir werden beide brauchen bis wir das bemannten machen aber ich glaube dass wir im prinzip die jacke hatte vorher schon mal wegschicken und da da landen und sozusagen sicherstellen dass wir da landen können sie erstellen das war alles querbeet haben
wahrscheinlich auch schon kühlschrank und dann sozusagen das als als vorbereitung für eine finde maß mist bemannte marsmission nehmen würden.
Also.
Nichts habe ich so viel skepsis wahrgenommen wenn man sich jetzt mal so bei anderen raumfahrt organisationen umhört wie zu diesem ganzen maß projekt einfach weil's natürlich eine extrem komplexe,
geschichte ist ich hatte das hier bei raum zeit auch schon ein paar mal im programm so untersuchungen psychologische untersuchung maß
fünfhundert von der esa wo halt geschaut wird wie verhalten sich menschen eigentlich wenn die irgendwie so lange gemeinsam eingeschlossen sind in einem raum und wie verhindern man das hier nicht alle auf sich losgehen solche aspekte und strahlung et cetera die belastung ist halt einfach extrem hoch
mit welchem ansatz geht es besser da ran einfach so einfach mal ausprobieren und mal gucken was passiert.
Na ganz so ganz so lapidar ist es nicht also wir haben wir haben programme die halt entsprechend da was weiß ich die die die die menschliche seite dabei
in betracht ziehen strahlung schutz und so weiter und so fort daran arbeiten wir haben auch andere die uns dabei helfen die die ganze logistik aufzubauen immer entsprechend am maß die logistik um treibstoff wieder zu bauen
zu entwickeln weil die ein grund warum wir halt methan fliegen an dem an dem triebwerk ist weil methan kann man aus der atmosphäre in,
also wasser am am maß gewinnen also da sind da gehört entsprechend auch kürbis dazu oder arbeiten halt auch entsprechend teams dran,
der.
Der hauptteil ist für uns momentan nach wie vor stark und das deswegen fokussieren wir darauf wir glauben der andere teil ist was was andere wo andere uns helfen könnten,
wo wir auch hilfe brauchen ist keine frage aber beim ist beim start chef selber ist das das ist das wo wir sehen wo wir wo wir glauben dass wir brauchen jetzt,
wir müssen jetzt handeln um das halt entsprechend auch in den nächsten jahren durchziehen zu können.
Das heißt aber auch dass man hier eigentlich einen kompletten neues system aufsetzen und herzlich wenig von dem alten von der alten technologie wiederverwenden kann also sicherlich das eine oder andere und software und so weiter.
Software.
Triebwerke zum beispiel sind ja jetzt komplett anders das ist ja ein vollständig anderes antriebsmodelle wie weit ist das.
Relativ weit wir haben immer sagen paar handvoll mindestens zwei handvoll triebwerke gebaut getestet.
Geht's halt immer wieder sachen wo man wo man wieder zurückgehen müssen nochmal veränderung machen muss ich würde sagen das ist so in einem punkt jetzt wo man,
langsam aus dem prototypen design herauskommt beim motor,
es hat auch ein relativ komplexer motor ist im gegensatz zu der falke nein motor ist ein gast generator zyklus und das ist ein sogenanntes stage compassion.
Keine ahnung was auf deutsch heißt.
Stage kompass schon heiß.
Genau das ist im prinzip wo man die brennstoffe nicht ganz komplett verbrennt dann durch die turbo pumpe drückt durch den durch das durch die turbine drückt und dann komplett in der brennkammer verbrannt.
Also eine mehrstufige.
Genau mehrstufige verbrennung ja und das ist halt eine ganze ecke komplizierter,
hat zwei zwei punkten statt eine und dann hat man auch eben getan was auch neue treibstoffe ist und diese ganzen kommt komplizierten sachen das ist etwas was wir im prinzip in den letzten zwei jahren schon,
zwei jahren mit gearbeitet haben und das heißt es gibt uns jetzt also im prinzip den vorsprung zu den rest der kälte die jetzt anfängt sich zu zu entwickeln.
Entsteht beim verbrennen von mechanischen menge wasser in dem prozess.
Wenig ahnung aber von den elementen her würde ich mal sagen da kannst du schaust wasser drin sein die flamme ist blau.
Die anderen raus.
Also sieht schon mal cooler aus wieder.
Genau sieht auf jeden fall coole aus das stimmt.
Also ein teil ist außerdem methan hat weniger sud weniger so überreste genau auf den turbinen und so sachen ist im prinzip auch besser für die wieder vereinbarkeit.
Also die idee ist letztlich dicke fette rakete bauen.
Hinfliegen landen vor ort neuen treibstoff generieren den man braucht und dann auch wieder zurück fliegen.
Gerade dieser letzte teil klingt ja nun extrem verwegen weil es ja jetzt nicht so dass man da irgendwie landet und es ist weil's da wars und da gibt's dann schon irgendwie eine kneipe um die ecke.
Ja nee gibt's nicht.
Die infrastruktur ist ja ja nun sehr gering ausgeprägt tempo.
Parolen die da rumliegen.
Ja aber die dienstleistungsqualität läuft ist jetzt auch nicht so ausgeprägt zumindest nicht für raketenstart ist auch jetzt nicht unbedingt das beste wetter temperaturen könnten auch besser sein.
Relativ relativ kalt.
Dazu braucht es ja dann auch erstmal technologie die vor ort ist also man muss ja sozusagen irgendwo erstmal wieder zurückkommen muss ja vor ort schon mal irgendwie eine fabrik dastehen wie soll die denn überhaupt entstehen.
Naja wir werden im prinzip unbemannte mission vorausschicken die das entsprechend dann schon mal der ablagern man muss da halt auch in der nähe landen,
das ist durchaus durch das auch nochmal so ein ding man muss halt entsprechend die navigation da haben ja ich meine es hat durchaus seine seine risiken als als erster mensch am maß,
würde ich mal sagen.
Auf jeden fall,
also ich nehme den ganzen dass es lebt auch ein wenig von seinem größenwahn das projekt ist sozusagen so komplex und so langfristig angelegt es wird einfach die momentum innerhalb des ladens noch lange aufrecht erhalten.
Also,
sie müssen ein bisschen wie man darauf guckt ja auf der einen seite kann man das ansehen und kann sagen oh das ist so viel ich schaffe das nicht und dann läuft wieder weg davon oder man sagt halt okay was ist kompliziert
ich fange mal mit dem teil an den ich auf jeden fall brauche und das ist die rakete ja und so das ist so ein bisschen so,
so ein bisschen zu erklären wie wir wie wir daran gehen ja da kommt der nächste schritt nach danach ja und es kann durchaus sein dass der schritte dabei sind wo wir sagen okay wir brauchen mehr zeit,
wir brauchen mehr entwicklung und wir brauchen hilfe hier und hilfe da das wird nicht überhaupt nicht wundern das ist das ich meine das ist ein ding was was eigentlich für länder fast fast zu viel ist ja,
und von daher würde mich nicht wundern wenn wir halt irgendwann mal sagen okay wir müssen irgendwie eine form finden wie wir,
mehr firmen oder mehr länder oder mehr organisation damit einbinden können ja ich meine wir haben ja auch durchaus da gibt's ja auch noch nasa und so,
da da muss irgendwas entstehen in meinen augen um das erfolgreich zu zu zu durchzuziehen am ende dass wir jetzt da keinen plan haben von a nach was weiß ich das,
das stimmt aber auf der anderen seite wir haben halt einen plan um den die erste große element die rakete das womit alles steht ein feld da haben wir den plan für.
Das bringt mich an den punkt mal auch zu hinterfragen wie steht so space-x da,
im verhältnis zu den anderen organisationen meine wir haben in den letzten jahrzehnten eine extrem national supranational geprägte raumfahrt struktur immer gehabt,
von den usa statt in europa der europäische komplex geht ja auch schon ein bisschen über europa hinaus die russen haben schon immer ihr süppchen gekocht die chinesen tun's
derzeit auch ganz extrem es heißt sehr viel des gesamten wissens um raumfahrt eine ganze erfahrung ist im wesentlichen eigentlich in diesen strukturen
jetzt kommt eigentlich nicht nur mit space ex blue paar andere unternehmen die jetzt in den usa so 'ne neue welle privatisiertes raumfahrt quasi neu definieren.
Gab es schon immer einen privaten anteil
all die unternehmen die räumfahrzeuge bauen satellitentechnik etcetera ist ja jetzt nicht so dass jetzt ausschließlich eine nationalisierten sache wäre aber zumindest so die großen mission die weiten
ziele die die die ganz großen träume wurden eigentlich bisher immer so auf dieser ebene gesponnen wie fühlt sich jetzt spacex dort,
ein wir sind so die diplomatischen beziehungen wie wie also vielleicht so aus der innenpool aktive heraus wie wie wie sieht man sich da oder in welchem verhältnis wäre man vielleicht auch gerne.
Also wir sind wir sind ganz klar ein partner und ja das nennt sich am public-private-partnership mit mit nasa und,
nase hat basics in einer ziemlich entscheidenden phase geholfen als wir damals eben was wir hier anfing mit falker nein und daneben entwickelt haben und und gleichzeitig haben wir nasa mit,
unsere entwicklung auch sehr geholfen über dieses problem in wegzukommen dass man das shuttle sozusagen retreat hat ohne,
ohne eine alternative zu haben ja und das hat man im prinzip auch weiterentwickelt woraufhin worauf jetzt auch entstanden ist.
Also eine alternative für bemannte.
Genau erst fassen wir mann der alternative nur für cargo sozusagen das war ja auch durchaus,
was was gebraucht wurde und dann jetzt ist es eine alternative zur zur matten im prinzip shuttle und,
ich denke mir das halt schon zwischen zwischen nasa und möglich eine arbeitsteilung wo wo spacex sozusagen die,
den service liefert wie man hat das transportiert ja und nasa im wesentlichen diese und zeit gibt was die transportiert haben möchten und auch so die groben ziele halt
worum es halt geht was weiß ich wo anders auf der station wir brauchen jenes auf der station wir brauchen so viele leute und so weiter und so fort vorgibt und dann auch entsprechend mit uns arbeitet ja wie der sich jetzt,
auf maß und stars ship erweitern lässt ist.
Würde ich sagen etwas was wir im nächsten jahr ausarbeiten müssen für die nächsten zwei jahren ja nasa ist ja momentan dabei wieder zum mond zurückzugehen mit atem ist und.
Und das ist auch ein projekt wo wir halt gerne mitmachen würden und unter anderem auch mit,
ja ich fahre falken nein fuck in heavy da die ganze palette alles was wir an produkten haben würden wir gerne dafür einsetzen ja und da,
kommt jetzt halt in den nächsten monaten vielleicht im nächsten jahr bei herum wie das passieren wird und wie sich das auch entsprechend dann,
erweitern lässt auf maß langfristig ja also tatsächlich ist du warte mal halt in diese diese bereiche kommt dann wird das durchaus,
wenn ich sage politisch aber es ist politisch glaube ich wo man halt entsprechend organisation hat die halt.
In ländern eingebunden sind und ihre eigenen sachzwänge haben ja das wahrscheinlich in europa noch ein bisschen schwieriger als in amerika wo man wo es im prinzip um nasa und die erfurt geht.
Und und wo wir halt auch mittlerweile relativ gut also relativ gute partnerschaften entwickelt haben.
Ja und auch ordentlich davon profitiert haben das relativ viele staatliche aufträge gegeben hat für space-x die ja dann auch eigentlich überdurchschnittlich gut bezahlt werden im vergleich zu dem kommerziellen sektor.
Das würde ich eigentlich gar nicht mal so sagen also die das muss man also zum beispiel.
Vergleichen zwischen männer waren immer zwei anbieter spezies und ein anderer anbieter ja und oftmals haben die anderen anbieter fünfzig prozent.
Mal gucken wie das büchel das genau war erheblich mehr bekommen also das basics war bei diesen ganzen sachen immer der billigere anbieter ja und oftmals auch traumatisch billiger,
und ich meine wenn man so vergleicht jetzt kommerziell und und und und ne dragon mission vergessen leute oftmals dass da noch drauf ist und
ist durchaus teuer ich ein großes großes special und da ist genau auf den arbeit rein und,
ist relativ komplex kann autonom an der an der station docken also das ist mir dein grund warum halt diese mission auch ewig teurer teurer sind.
Ja ja ich wollte nicht damit unterstellen dass bei sex jetzt irgendwie alles geschenkt wird ich sage nur der der markt ist halt dadurch noch mal stärker als ein rein kommerzieller markt wäre und das hat sicherlich aus basics geholfen die position zu kommen wo es heute ist.
Ja ich würde mal sagen auf jeden fall es ist keine frage des nase nase ist also wir sind die sind sehr dankbar was nasa und auch die erfurt.
Und sozusagen die möglichkeit gegeben haben diese diese sachen zu entwickeln aber da waren ja eben auch durchaus eigenentwicklung von basics dabei nicht also da war fabian heavy
ist eine eigene entwicklung von uns gewesen und und so so war nein und nase hat dann im prinzip uns
da hat er dir gemacht ok es ist etwas wofür wir gerne die ressourcen und fundings hätten.
Das heißt die traditionelle doppelte aufgaben zuschnitt der nasa sowohl für die raumfahrt zuständig zu sein als auch die ganze science gemacht wird wird sich,
perspektivisch mehr ins heinz richtung verschieben während der raumfahrt teil von privaten unternehmen in zukunft.
Zum beispiel das ist so der trend in der momentan zu sehen ist das sind auch durchaus elemente in der raum vorteil wo nasa nach wie vor daran arbeitet nicht mein.
Nach wie vor satelliten sind in unter nase entwickelt große teleskope und so weiter und so fort da gibt's also haufen haufenweise noch sachen wo nase eben selber was entwickelt und das selbe macht aber im prinzip raketen bauen
naja im prinzip waren es immer aufträge die halt rausgegeben wurden an andere firmen das modell ist ein bisschen anders mit den commercial anbietern.
Bis jetzt mit den diplomatischen beziehungen zu den anderen ländern organisationen aus.
Aus.
Welche.
Naja da ist oftmals auch ein bisschen der wettbewerb drin nicht also wenn's einem dann ist halt oftmals hat oftmals areal was damit zu tun oder sojus und von daher ist es.
Es ist nicht so dass keine europäischen mission gibt die basics raumfahrt realisiert werden würden.
Nicht viel.
Nicht viel aber einige ein paar.
Ein paar oftmals oftmals vor super sowieso kooperation mit in amerika schon vorgesehen waren also nicht viele und,
ja also im prinzip hat jede organisation füttert sozusagen ihre rakete sozusagen nicht und von daher ist es immer schwierig,
ja ich würde zum beispiel gerne mal einen richtig großen deutschen satelliten fliegen das ist so so mein mein mein ziel,
und das ist momentan einfach schwierig.
Ja kann ich mir vorstellen ein paar mal haben wir es jetzt schon erwähnt dragon und aktuell bringen zwei ist ja auch schon geflogen oder.
Zwei ist geflogen am im märz und zwar unter der demo eins mission.
Also die kapsel die zur geflogen ist und benannt die halt im wesentlichen für die versorgung zuständig ist da gab es ja auch jetzt jahrelang die kapsel der europäer
die dort geflogen ist fünfmal dann kam es dragon stärker zum einsatz mittlerweile kann,
trinken auch drink zwei ist quasi dann eben auch diese wiederverwendbare zeit ein thema oder.
Nee wir benutzen eigentlich dagegen eins schon wieder sagen eins ist bisher dreimal geflogen dass das meiste was wir gemacht haben.
Dragon zwei oder crew hat halt den zum einen ist es eben eine kapsel die für für
astronauten gebaut wurde das sind dann nicht nur drei campingstühle da drin sondern eben viel wir vier stühle lebenserhaltungssystem und so weiter und so fort und alles ist,
mehr mehr sicherheit ausgelegt worden und,
dann hat es vor allen dingen auch ein eines mechanismus das heißt wenn es sein muss kann die kapsel sich von der rakete trennen und dann kurz triebwerk entzünden und zehn sekunden später ist es halt auch sehr aus dem gefahrenbereich heraus ja,
und dann außerdem ein ein ein anderer wesentlicher unterschiede sondern zwei dog und,
wohingegen tag in eins das ist der unterschied dass sozusagen doping ist aktiv da fährt man an die station ran und fährt zu dem jogging port dran wohingegen bölting ist da,
da wird man von der station sozusagen mit dem arm gekrabbelt aufgegriffen und dann zu einem port hingebracht.
Andere andere technologie ein bisschen bisschen schneller auch wenn man wenn man jogging macht und was war das letzte nochmal,
zu sachen so des wagener radio ist weg das ist mittlerweile nur noch die die der untere teil mit solarzellen bedeckt das reicht mittlerweile
erhebliche erhebliche verbesserungen grundsätzlich was die nichts und die die elektronik auch angeht.
Das heißt die kapsel macht jetzt im prinzip auch diese autonome andocken was ja ursprünglich von der esa mit dem automaten transfer wege glaube ich pioniere wurde es war die erste automatisch andocken kapsel an der.
Ich glaube das stimmt aber wie genau wir hatten andere methode ursprünglich wo wir halt mit diesem arm aufgegriffen wurde der vorteil von dem arm ist im prinzip dass die dass das tor die tür ist breiter,
eigentlich ziemlich trivial mal die tür ist halt ein meter mal meter und dann kann man halt was was was ich was anderes meter groß ist oder eins komma vier meter.
Also bei einer anderen stelle auch andockt.
Genau eben ja und damit kann man große sachen reinbringen der vorteil von der von dem jogging mechanismus ist im prinzip für dich für die kapsel ist es kleiner und man braucht den arm nicht,
eines meiner größten sorge war immer was ist wenn der arm kaputt geht ja dann haben wir ein problem da kann man dann nicht mehr ran,
und dann den jogging machen müssen was ist das im prinzip nicht mehr ein problem und nicht dass der arme kaputt geht also ganz klar zu sein,
tanzen alles ja aber das war so immer so geht zu einem solchen kopf wenn man so sachen so sachen machen was ist denn wenn der arm gehabt machen wir denn dann.
Aber die kanadier haben bisher ganz gute arbeit geleistet wie es aussieht.
Genau genau.
Ja jetzt gibt's ja noch,
eine ganz neue perspektive dass ich space-x nicht nur als raumfahrt provider und bauer engagiert sondern mit dem starlink projekt was jetzt letzte woche du bist,
mal schon satelliten ausgesetzt hat es sind glaube ich wie viele sind jetzt schon irgendwie im sechzigsten zugekommen und vierzig waren schon da oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich war nur sprünge also sagen wir mal so zwei waren es ganz ursprünglich,
ich bin nicht mehr ganz sicher ob die nach oben sind und da hatten wir in der ersten welle die wahl getestet haben jetzt haben wir die zweite welle neu neues update am satelliten das heißt wir haben im prinzip hundertzwanzig hundertzweiundzwanzig satteln um,
genau wir sind wir haben damit schon eine ziemlich große kunst.
Aber es soll ja noch einige kommen man muss vielleicht an der stelle nochmal kurz erwähnen was das eigentlich ist und inwiefern das eben was neues ist weil es handelt sich ja um eine,
satelliten infrastruktur zur schnellen übertragung von internet kann man lässt sich.
Dann passiert nichts als nichts als als internet.
Genau aber mit einer extrem hohen anzahl an satelliten was ist so der finale ausbau.
Ja gut ich meine das da gibt es also ein sogenanntes feeling mit der mitte oder was immer diese organisation da ist ja was halt die maximale größe ich glaube auf dreißigtausend momentan festlegt ja das ist so ein bisschen.
Sagen wir mal ob optimistisch soweit könnte es wenn alles funktioniert dass es was man brauchen könnte ja und dann will man halt auch entsprechend entsprechendes so vorsehen dass es auch entsprechend die die die dass man da nicht irgendwie,
probleme hat von der von der regulatorik von der von den von den behörden dagegen irgendwie eine obergrenze läuft.
Was man jetzt tatsächlich braucht um dir zum laufen zu kriegen das sind alles erheblich weniger,
wir werden direkt noch ein bisschen davon ab wo man auf der erde ist aber mit den ersten siebenhundert wird das also schon in den breiten.
Um fünfzig grad ist das glaube ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher meine zahlen also ich kenne nicht so genau ja,
jedenfalls in bestimmten geographischen breiten kann man dann schon auch vernünftig internet kriegen und dann mit mehr staat wird das halt immer besser.
Genau weil das netz dann halt dichter wird diese einzelnen sehr klein satelliten kommunizieren untereinander über laser technologie und bauen im prinzip den schnellsten weg auf wo man quasi,
wieder herunter kommen muss um schnell die daten dort hin zu bringen wo sie hin sollen.
Zum einen sind sie gar nicht mal ja wir sind halt so schon kleinere satelliten verglichen mit großen gierstädt satelliten aber die haben halt durchaus auch schon eine gewisse ausdehnung lag eine ratte der hat ein paar quadratmeter.
Warum warum ich das jetzt überhaupt noch mal so aufziehe und so bemerkenswert finde ist das ja hier space-x selber eigentlich auch zu den dienstag anbieter wird normalerweise gibt's ja hier eine eine klare trennung unternehmen die satelliten hochschicken die machen halt genau das aber kaum ist das ding im im all hat man damit ja nichts mehr zu tun
in diesem fall ist das ja ein eigentliche projekt von space-x das heißt bass-x wird jetzt
auch dienste anbieter in dem fall halt ein internet satelliten basierter internet provider das bedeutet ja dass das unternehmen sich auch nochmal in der richtung komplett neu,
und anders aufstellt als es bisher traditionell in dem bereich gewesen ist.
Also das ist wahr das ist eine erweiterung von dem von unserem spektrum was wir halt bisher nicht gemacht haben und vor allen dingen werden wir damit auch eine organisation die halt dann,
kunden hat,
die halt ja millionen kunden hat nicht und das ist durchaus verspätet sex noch einen schritt der gut ich meine tesla hatten hatten uns gezeigt wie man das so ein bisschen machen kann oder so das sind die auch nicht
du hast ja mittlerweile auch tesla ist von daher haben wir haben wir ein bisschen erfahrung im haus wie das halt läuft nicht aber
das wird mit sicherheit noch mal für uns auch gerne eine gelegenheit sein zu lernen.
Es ist aber auf jeden fall auch ein sehr ambitioniertes projekt also,
der lounge ist richtig gesehen habe die sechzig satelliten die werden ja sozusagen auch so in in einem paket,
rausgeschoben außer rakete normalerweise machen wir jetzt mehrere satelliten an bord hat wenn ja dann auch einzeln rausgeschubst in diesem fall geht sozusagen der komplette blog alleine raus und dann lösen die sich einfach nur voneinander und.
Was man nicht sieht ist dass die die die oberstufe dreht sich dabei ja und und das ist praktisch wie eine zentrale vogel ja
ein bisschen langsamer aber die die die satelliten bewegen sich deswegen auch auseinander wenn sie als block rausgeschmissen werden,
also das ist schon das schon ein bisschen physik dahinter das ist auseinander geht ja das ist nicht nur das wir die einfach einfach über bord schmeißen da ist schon man sieht schon wie die langsam auseinander gehen das ist.
Es ist ein bisschen schwierig zu sehen an in der in der kamera weil es halt so schnell geht ja aber langfristig kann man auch sehen wie die auseinandergehen da so eine perlenkette bilden bis dann die satelliten auch anfangen aufzuwachen und dann in ihren eigenen orbit sich sich beschaffen.
Wie lange dauert das bis die linie jetzt gelauncht und dann auch tatsächlich im orbit sind weil es ja eine relativ langsamer ionen antrieb sehr lang anhalten aber mit relativ wenig wumms das könnte eine weile dauern oder.
Genau das dauert ein soweit ich weiß aber dass ein paar wochen also nicht,
nicht jetzt irgendwie ein halbes jahr oder so aber doch halt entsprechend ein paar wochen bisher halt eben in dem orbit sind wo sie auch nachher dann portioniert betrieben werden und in den worten müssen sie halt auch entsprechend immer triebwerk benutzen um dann halt eben entsprechend in arbeit zu stabilisieren und und dran zu bleiben.
Da muss ich aber jetzt besser ist ja im prinzip auch noch ein eigenes raumfahrt kontrollzentrum zu.
Genau ich meine wir haben ja eh schon eh schon dragon fliegt dann ist da konstanten kontrollzentrum michael control in der in horn und von daher,
da die infrastruktur haben wir auch wir haben auch die die bodenstation dafür schon,
ich weiß gar nicht genau wie viel aber wir haben einige bodenstation in der welt verteilt und das sind alles sachen die wir die wir im prinzip worauf er zurückgreifen können.
Das heißt demnächst gibt's iphone dann auch mit mit starlink.
Mit mit dem styling styling das wäre das wäre nicht schlecht ja prima.
Ich weiß gar nicht was technisch überhaupt angedacht dass.
Nee man braucht man braucht eine man braucht eine antenne am boden die ein bisschen größer ist als ein iphone,
noch nicht also wenn man vielleicht mal dann irgendwann mal auf höhere frequenzen gehen vielleicht aber momentan ist die antenne aufm boden ungefähr so groß wie die pizza.
Sieht ein bisschen anders aus als die die reflektoren die man halt hier an den häusern immer sieht ja ja und und das was halt oben aufs dach kommt sie ziemlich schick aus,
ich bin ziemlich sicher ich werde das auch ausprobieren und gucken wie's geht und die die idee ist halt vor allen dingen schnelles und verzögerungs-und freies internet zu kriegen.
Genau die niedrigere latenz ist ja hier ein versprechen man wundert sich wenn es irgendwie einmal ins all geht dann ist doch auch ganz schön viel weg zurück zu gehen aber großer vorteil,
kommunikation im all ist halt schneller als im glasfaserkabel und es bringt richtig was.
Naja also der großteil beruht darauf dass der das ist das sind sogenannte galloways die sachen hoch schicken ja und die sind halt neben neben,
den populationen zentrum sozusagen oder da wo man halt dementsprechend den den service verkauft also nicht so dass da irgendwie das signal von satelliten zu satellit weitergereicht mit großartiger soll idealerweise auf auf dem sattel drunter zu zu zu was weiß ich in ihrer nähe.
Telefon ja eben nicht aber zu hause halt nicht.
Ja genau also man hat quasi so so feste ablegen und down links die halt die verbindung zu diesem gefüge im all halten aber wenn man dorthin den weg schnell findet dann ist halt der weg,
durch die ganze satelliten der sozusagen von satelliten satellit weitergereicht werden wird vergleichsweise schnell obwohl es eben im.
Was ich grade sagen wollte am anfang wenn wir nicht viel weiterreichen ja am anfang war das größtenteils vom boden satellit auf einen benutzer gehen und das ist halt eben auch wo es versicherungsfrei ist weil die strecke relativ kurz ist also relativ.
Jetzt gab es so bei den bei den astronomen,
viel aufregung ob dieses projektes weil die aussicht nochmal dreißigtausend satelliten ins allzu entlassen wo es ja,
bisher in der geschichte der raumfahrt noch nicht so viele satelliten gestartet worden sind,
macht so ein bisschen angst weil die dinge haben natürlich auch solarpanelen sprich,
die leuchten auch und dann kriegen wir sozusagen mal ein ganz neue form von lichtverschmutzung in die diskussion,
ist das überhaupt ein realistisches szenario wie sichtbar wird diese konstellation sein.
Also ich glaube nicht und zwar erstens mal solargeneratoren schauen auf die sonne das heißt das einzige was sie sozusagen reflektieren ist zurück zur sonne und solange wir nicht sind ist es glaube ich okay.
Okay man kennt das ja so von den flyers von der auch selber also wenn die konstellation halt stimmt dann sind sie halt kurz zu sehen.
Was man oft kennt sind die flairs ja aber das sind die antennen und das sind nicht die nicht die solargeneratoren.
Echt.
Ja und das ist was ganz anderes ja also von daher glaube ich nicht dass wir da irgendwas an bord haben was halt grundsätzlich als flair irgendwie auftauchen wird,
ich glaube auch die zahlen gut wie gesagt bei den zahlen müssen wir mal sehen dass wir tatsächlich,
zu dieser zu diesem punkt kommen würden und was halt so ein bisschen.
Irreführend ist meiner meinung nach ist dass die wenn wir die aussetzen ist das so ein bisschen so ein kleiner kleiner zug nicht und so ein train von sechzig satelliten und das ist halt irgendwie eine dimension was man nicht gewöhnt ist innerhalb von paar tagen bricht das auf wenn es weg,
und von daher ich glaube das ist dieser anfängliche zug den man dann sieht wo man denkt oh ja das ist was was man wirklich jede zeit jederzeit zieht das später auch aus das ist nicht der fall ja das ist.
Ist halt nur am anfang weil die halt dann auch ein bisschen durch die gegend zu rollen und und hat alle zusammenhängen ja was eigentlich auch durchaus bemerkenswert ist wenn man das sehen kann ja,
später wird man das nicht mehr sehen und was die anzahl der satelliten angeht ich meine es gibt einen haufen satelliten da oben es gibt auch einen haufen objekte die nicht registriert sind und es gibt einen haufen objekte die man,
jemand sehen könnte auf der anderen seite des,
er hat auch ein haufen haufen überall um uns herum also ich würd's ich habe noch nicht die zeit gehabt ich würde gerne mal nachrichten was die wahrscheinlichkeit ist dass man halt mehr als,
was weil ich zwei oder drei über den gesamten horizont hat ja weil im prinzip die konstellation ist ja so so aufgebaut dass man halt maximal weniger als eine handvoll satelliten sehen kann,
was ist eigentlich die idee dahinter wenn man mehr sehen würde wenn zu viel satelliten ist doch nicht machen ja,
also von daher ist es ein bisschen nicht nicht ganz logisch was ich was ich was da irgendwie muss ich da irgendwie höre und in meinen augen auch wirklich angetrieben von diesem von diesem bild da wie man das sieht wie die ganzen satelliten aufgereiht sind.
Das ende ist also noch nicht nah.
Nein das ende ist nicht na ich würde mal vielleicht ein bisschen rechnen und zu sehen wie groß das all tatsächlich ist das ist relativ groß.
So das ende ist aber nah für dieses gespräch,
das habe ich schon fast nichts mehr hier in meinen notizen.
Habe ich noch irgendwas ganz gibt's noch irgendetwas wichtiges auf dass man vielleicht auch mal die aufmerksamkeit richten sollte bei space-x auf die normalerweise nicht so geschaut wird.
Na wir haben im prinzip über alles gesprochen ich ich meine was ich was ich einfach was für mich einfach auch wichtig ist ist halt dass aus diesem.
Aus diesem ewigen na ja würde ich mal sagen kreis oder zyklus wie man normalerweise raumfahrt bisher gemacht hat in den letzten in den letzten dreißig vierzig jahren,
da finde ich brechen wir heraus und das ist etwas was ich eigentlich auch sehr erfrischend finde und sehr schön finde ich fände es schön wenn andere das auch machen würden und wenn wir ein bisschen mehr,
sagen wir mal,
bisschen mehr gemeinsamkeiten anderen firmen hätten die halt eben auch solche sachen machen ja und mehr mehr wettbewerb hatten in dem sinne auch das firmen gibt die halt entsprechend,
aus dem kreis aus dem zyklus der der der staatlichen förderung und so weiter herausbrechen und und ihre eigenen sachen machen das das wäre durchaus was was der raum voll helfen könnte ja mir ist es wichtig dass die raumfahrt weiterlebt,
dabei ist es eben einfach auch wichtig dass wir den nächsten schritt machen der nächste schritt in meinen augen ist mond oder mars ja müssen wir einfach hin.
Ja ich bin dabei also ich schaue mir das gerne an ich fliege aber nicht mit.
Gut ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht zum maßen auch nicht zum mond aber ja.
Ja also ich habe es zumindest schon mal den kopf geschafft das fand ich schon ziemlich bemerkenswert über die anforderungen mit jedem kilometer die man weiter nach oben steigt die sind dann doch schon erheblich.
Aber elon musk scheint ja unbeirrt zu sein tatsächlich hier unseres pferden zu verlassen.
Sagen wir mal so ich würde euch was auch auch zur station fliegen weil weil ich glaube dass es tatsächlich ganz angenehm ist mal eine woche schwerelos zu sein ich glaube nicht ich meine das so auf die ganzen ganzen gelenke auf die schmerzen glaube ich.
Na ja das geht nicht das kriegt man danach dann aber wieder doppelt wenn sich die wenn sich der rücken erstmal durchgestreckt hat dann hat das auch wieder mit der gravitation.
Genau ja nee.
Du kriegst nichts geschenkt.
Hallo,
ich glaube von der von der körperlichen sache her ist es ist das durchaus schaffbar ist nicht nicht besonders schwierig von der psychologischen und mentalen sache,
gut da muss man halt ein bisschen entsprechend vor vielleicht trainieren und sich darüber im klaren sein dass man halt in einem engen raum ist.
Aber elon musk möchte auch schon so zum masters ja dann auch wieder zurückkommt.
Das müssen sie ihn selber fragen oder ich fahre ins nächste mal wenn ich ihn sehe.
Alles klar dann liefern diese information vielleicht nochmal nach vielen vielen dank herr königs- mann.
Vielen dank alles klar gern geschehen.
Es war super ein rundumschlag zu spacex und ja ich sag vielen dank fürs zuhören hier bei raum zeit das war's.